So I'm going to read you something.
I get some,
I get a lot of mail and I don't know
where I got this.
I have been a lot of different places in
the last week and this showed up at one
of them and I'm going to read it to you.
I have no idea what to make of it.
It's written in a female hand.
So that's about all I can tell,
but there's no address or name on it.
This isn't a question,
but a comment or more accurately perhaps
a message.
I spent this past weekend in an Iowaska
ceremony,
which for those of you who don't know is
a South American visionary plant
medicine.
Some of you may roll your eyes at this,
but IOWASCA brings you into direct
contact with the archetypal realm of
being.
Users of this medicine initiates,
I should say,
refer to Iowasca as she because the
spirit of the plant is decidedly
feminine and encounter with Iowasca is
an encounter with the great mother of
creation,
the goddess,
the void from which all things come.
The Feminine counterpart of Logos,
Dr Peterson,
you appeared in one of my Osca visions.
Thank you.
Might account for why have been rather
fatigued late.
Dr Peterson.
You appeared in one of my Iowasca
visions and I asked,
I asked her,
who is Jordan Peterson?
What is he doing that which is something
I'd really like to know as well,
and she responded with Kristalina
clarity quote here he is here to invoke
and initiate the divine masculine
principle on earth at this time.
Thank you.
So I'm up here to thank you deeply and
profoundly on behalf of the great mother
herself,
the goddess,
the divine feminine principle who has
been eagerly awaiting the awakening of
the masculine principle into divinity
and service.
So,
you know,
get a letter like that every day.
Actually I get a letter to like that
every day.
So you know what went through my head
when I read this and this is of course
completely crazy,
but we know one of the things I learned
to do as a psychotherapist was just to
tell people who were talking to me,
what came into my head,
what I'm thinking.
Exactly.
Because that's not exactly the same
thing,
you know what comes into your head is
more like a dream.
It comes unbidden and it's like your
imagination.
If you're thinking,
there seems to be like a voluntary
element of that,
right?
I mean some of who God only knows how we
think,
but it.
It seems partly voluntary at least,
and you only thought about it,
Carl young thought about it like a
dialogue between the conscious mind and
the unconscious mind.
There was a constant continual dialogue,
but when things just pop into your mind,
it's not much different than walking
into a room.
Having something there,
which is an observation.
I also derived from young by the way,
because he pointed out quite rightly
that people don't really think that
thoughts appear to them.
Now you can think because you can take
the thoughts that appear to you and then
you can subject them to criticism and
elaboration and so on instead of just
assuming that they're true right off the
bat,
but people often don't do that.
They just.
Something just pops into their head and
then they assume that it's true.
Anyways.
One of the things that I tend to do in
psychotherapy is just to tell people
what pops into my head because,
well,
why?
Because then the person that is talking
to me gets one person's untrammeled
opinion.
Not even that reaction,
not opinion.
It's not really an opinion.
I don't think an opinion maybe is what I
think later.
And there's this personal flavor to it.
What popped into my head was this story
about socrates,
you know,
he had this when he was being put on
trial by the Athenians for corrupting
the nation's youth.
Something I've been accused of by the
way,
although it's not self evident to me
that it's me doing the corrupting.
Um,
he said that somebody had asked him
once,
had asked the delphic oracle once and
the delphic oracle was this retreat that
you could go to if you were an ancient
Greek citizen and you'd,
you'd,
you'd be there and you'd have a dream
and then you'd go ask the delphic oracle
to interpret it.
And nobody really knows what was up with
the delphic oracle today,
how that worked exactly.
But she would interpret your dream in
any case.
And somebody wants to ask her who the
wisest man in Greece was and the delphic
oracle said it was socrates because he
knew he didn't know anything.
That's essentially the story that popped
into my mind.
It's a crazy comparison.
But you know,
I have a crazy wine so I guess that's
how it works out.
So now one of the things I'm going to do
today,
which I haven't done before because I'm
going to read you a little bit of.
I told you I finished my book last week
and I haven't read it,
read to anyone.
I have given it to a couple of friends
to review a one person in particular,
a screenwriter named Gregg Hurwitz has
been unbelievably helpful.
He's so fast and so sharp at this sort
of thing and I can send him like a 20
page dense 20 page manuscript and he'll
rip it to shreds and send it back to me
and like 90 minutes.
It's just unbelievable.
He's so good at that.
He's been very helpful,
but I haven't.
No one else has seen it depart from my
editor and I haven't read it to anyone.
So.
But some of it seemed particularly
appropriate for tonight's lecture,
so I thought I would start the lecture
tonight by reading a little bit of it,
and it's.
It's from a chapter.
It's on the issue of sacrifice as such.
This is Abraham and Isaac.
This is a very strange old testament
story,
right?
This is one of the stories that's
contained in the old testament that
makes modern people think that maybe we
should just not have that much to do
with the old testament per say it at
all,
and especially with regards and maybe
shouldn't have anything to do with the
god of the Old Testament either.
Because I mean,
as far as Abraham is concerned,
God tells him to sacrifice his own son.
Now it turns out that God was just
kidding,
so to speak.
You know,
I'm obviously being flippant,
but it does raise the question,
what do you make of a divine being?
Who would,
who would require such thing,
such a thing?
Or conversely,
what do you make of Abraham who would
have such delusions?
Either way,
it's a little hard on the what would you
call modern believability and moral
integrity of the Old Testament,
but these are very,
very strange storks and they're not what
they seem to be or they are,
but they're more so.
We're going to talk a lot about
sacrifice tonight and here's some of the
things that I've been thinking about
sacrifice.
So this is from.
This book is called 12 rules for life,
an antidote for chaos and it's coming
out in January,
which I think I mentioned and this is
from rule seven,
which is do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
And so here's,
here's some of the writing I've been
doing over the last three years on the,
on the Motif of sacrifice.
I'll start with just a brief intro
before I read this.
It took me a long time to understand
what was meant in the Old Testament by
sacrifice and which is strange because
once I figured it out,
it seemed bloody obvious.
It seemed like,
oh y'all.
Obviously that's what it means,
but lots of times if you figure
something out correctly,
it seems self evident as soon as you
figured it out correctly.
Well,
we'll see how that goes,
but it seemed to work for me anyways.
I knew that of course,
at least implicitly I knew of the modern
usage of the idea of sacrifice.
Everyone understands that Motif is that
if you want to make things better in the
future,
then you make sacrifices in the present
and maybe you even do that
multi-generationally.
In fact,
you most definitely do if you're a good
parent.
I mean,
and that's I would say that's really
particularly typical of of of immigrants
because immigrants often come from
terrible places and have to undergo
terrible things to come to a new
community where they get a rough
reception and have a hard time getting
their life going and a big part of the
reason that they do it is to make their
lives of their children better and
luckily when they come to Canada,
usually given where they came from,
that actually works because where they
came from is worse and here is better.
Even though you know immigrants often
have to struggle to to get on their feet
again,
they have to learn a new language and
becoming culturated and face the fact
that they're not part of the mainstream
culture and well,
you know,
many of you know the whole story,
so the idea that you make sacrifices for
the future and you make sacrifices for
your children and that's everyone
understands that and it's part of being
responsible and mature and shouldering
the burden of being properly,
and you do that for yourself too.
If you're disciplined in,
in fact,
that's almost what discipline means.
That discipline means that you're
capable of making sacrifices because
you're not disciplined.
If you just do something you want more
rather than something that you're doing
that's not disciplined,
that's maybe that works then great.
If your life is working out that way,
great man,
but that isn't.
That isn't disciplined.
This is plan is when you want to do
something right now and instead you
think,
no,
I'm going to forestall my gratification.
Maybe forever,
but certainly for a very long period of
tar medium to long period of time and
you concentrate on something that you
think will bear fruit in the medium to
long run,
and so you'll look into the future and
you decide that by making today a little
less impulsively pleasurable,
shall we say you'll make tomorrow a
little bit more secure and productive
and then you actually do it too.
And that's difficult.
You know,
and we discussed last week,
Adam and Eve's discovery of the future
and the revelation of the possibility of
the future,
including the possibility of tragedy and
suffering in the future.
And it's our knowledge of the
possibility of tragedy and suffering in
the future that motivates us to
sacrifice in the present so that we can
reduce the unnecessary anxiety and
uncertainty and pain that awaits us.
Now.
That's a negative way of putting it.
We're also doing it so that we can have
some joy and we can make life better and
all of that.
And,
and that's not trivial,
but the fundamental issue,
especially once you have small children,
this fundamental issue is to stave the
suffering the hell off,
right?
That's what you want to do.
That's your primary moral obligation.
If you're a person who has any,
if your eyes are open at all,
that's your primary obligation and so
you make the sacrifices that are
necessary and you set up the future and
well,
the the Motif of sacrifice is there in
the Old Testament,
but it's more,
it's so concrete that it's difficult to
draw a parallel between the two.
At least for me,
they didn't align self evidently and I
don't remember in my rather limited
religious education as a child in the
United Church because I went to the
United Church till I was about 13.
I don't ever remember anybody pointing
out that the sacrifices that can enable,
we're making or the sacrifice that
Abraham was supposed to make or the
sacrifices that people were making to
God.
We're the call were the precursors,
let's say the dramatic precursors to the
psychological idea of sacrifice that we
all hold as civilized people in the
modern world.
So although it seems obvious,
as I said,
once you lay it out,
I don't remember that ever being
explained to me,
but,
and then,
well,
and then let me read this.
So now that I sort of introduced it,
here's what happened.
As humanity developed,
first we're the endless tens or hundreds
of thousands of years prior to the
emergence of written history and drama,
the twin practices of delay and exchange
began to emerge slowly and painfully.
So here's a cool psychological study.
So it's called the marshmallow test and
maybe it's even a reliable study.
Even though it was done by social
psychologists,
it's probably replicable and it's a nice
study.
So you take small children and you bring
them into a room and you put something
that they would like in front of them,
a marshmallow and you then you torture
them.
Basically you say see that marshmallow
and the things I see that marshmallow.
It's like you can have that marshmallow
right now or if you wait,
I think the experiment is 10 minutes.
Then you can have two marshmallows.
And so that puts the child in quite a
conundrum because they're being asked to
trade in actual concrete,
tangible marshmallow for two
hypothetical future marshmallows and
it's not that easy to conjure up a
hypothetical future reality that has the
same tangible significance as something
real right in front of you.
And so it's amazing thing that people
can do that.
And so then the experimenter leaves and
some children's grabbed the marshmallow
and just chomp that thing down right
now.
Other kids,
they videotaped kids while they're
waiting and they do all sorts of things.
They whistled,
they look at the ceiling,
they sit on their hands,
you know,
they try to distract themselves.
Course they're eyeing that marshmallow,
like a squirrel lying and not and,
and trying to restrain themselves.
And you know,
what I see in that is that the child's
prefrontal Cortex,
the higher cortical systems are warring
with the underlying motivational
systems,
more primordial motivational systems
that govern such things as hunger.
The hunger system,
hypothalamic system says there is
something sweet and fat,
right?
Sitting there,
right bloody.
Now grab that thing and stuff it down.
Now,
and I'm sure many of you have a constant
battle with your hypothalamus with
regards to sweet and fat things and
often lose so you can feel some sympathy
for the child,
but the hypothalamus has these
tremendously powerful tendrils upward
into the brain,
into the parts that we would associate
more with voluntary control and the
voluntary control centers have these
little weak ribbons going down to
control the hypothalamus since it's
pretty obvious if you know something
about neuroanatomy,
what part is actually in charge when the
chips are down,
and it's not easy for children to learn
to regulate those underlying primordial
impulses.
The ones that are wired in,
the ones that we share with animals,
but they do it and,
and,
and the cool thing is,
this is what Walter Michelle found.
He's the guy who did the study,
was that the longterm outcome for the
children who can delay gratification in
the marshmallow test is much more
positive than it is for the children
that are impulsive and eat the
marshmallow instantly.
It's delay of gratification.
Now it's likely that that's associated
with trait conscientiousness,
although that specifically has that
specific connection has not yet been
established,
but they seem conceptually very,
very similar.
Um,
so,
so anyways,
this emerges in children probably
between the ages of two and four,
something like that.
They should have it in place by four
because it's very difficult for them to
really interact well with other children
without having that delay of
gratification in place because you can't
delay gratification.
Other kids don't like you because
you're,
you want everything your way and you
want it now and you're,
you're liable to temper tantrums and
that sort of thing.
You haven't got to kind of self control
necessary to make you fun to play with.
So you can see that emerging in children
and it's pretty.
It's pretty interesting.
And not only that,
if it emerges,
it predicts positive longterm outcomes,
just like trait conscientiousness does,
by the way,
because trait conscientiousness is the
second best predictor of longterm
success over the lifespan.
In Western cultures,
it's second after intelligence.
And so in our societies,
the people who do best across time are
the people who have high iqs and who
work hard,
and I would say that's a pretty decent,
what would you call it?
It's a validation in some sense that our
cultures are working properly because
what you would want,
I would say if the system is working
meritocratic
Lee like it should,
and if you're trying to extract
resources from those who can contribute
at a higher rate than what you would
want to have happen is that the
hardworking,
smart people do better.
Hopefully.
If that's the case,
then everyone does better hopefully
anyways,
so you can see this developing in
children first worthy,
endless tens or hundreds of thousands of
years.
Prior to the emergence of written
history and drama,
the twin practices of delay and exchange
began to emerge slowly and painfully.
They hadn't.
They became represented in metaphorical
abstraction as rituals and tales of
sacrifice.
It says,
if there's a powerful figure in the sky
who's judging you,
you better keep them happy or look the
hell out.
We've been watching ourselves deal with
him for a long time.
He seems to like it when you give up
something you value,
so practice sharing and sacrificing
until you get good at it.
No one actually said any of this so long
ago,
although they said something very
similar,
but it was implicit in the practice and
then in the stories action comes first.
Implicit comes first.
People watched the successful succeed
and the unsuccessful fail for thousands
and thousands of years and we thought it
over and we drew a conclusion.
The successful among us sacrifice,
the successful among us,
delay gratification,
the successful among us bargain with the
future,
and then a great idea begins to emerge
in evermore articulated form.
That idea is the point of a long and
profound story.
It's the moral of this story and I'm
going to engage in some foreshadowing
here.
What's the difference between the
successful and the unsuccessful?
The successful sacrifice and things get
better as the successful practice.
There are sacrifices.
The question becomes increasingly
precise and simultaneously broader.
What is the greatest possible sacrifice
for the greatest possible?
Good.
No.
If you.
If you push a question in section,
perhaps there comes a time when you
can't formulate it any more precisely
and broadly and and,
and that,
that,
that's the point at which the question
in some sense,
and perhaps even the answer,
the question becomes archetipal,
it becomes archetipal because it,
it can't be bested and,
and this is like an ultimate question in
some sense.
How are you going to ask a more broad
based question than that?
What is given the initial
presuppositions that you have to make
sacrifices?
Then the logical end point to that is
something like,
okay,
if you have to make a sacrifice,
was the greatest possible sacrifice and
for the greatest possible good.
Now that's a good question.
The answer becomes increasingly
profound.
The God of Western tradition,
like so many gods requires sacrifice.
We've already examined why,
but sometimes he goes even further and
requires the sacrifice of what is love
best.
This is why,
and this is another one of mankind's
fundamental discoveries.
Sometimes things do not go well,
that,
that self evident,
but here's the rub.
Sometimes when things are not going
well,
it's precisely that which is most
valued.
That is the cause,
why?
It's because the world is revealed
through the template of your values.
If the world you are seeing is not the
world you want,
therefore it's time to examine your
values.
It's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions.
There's a famous experiment that I've
alluded to a couple of times I believe
in this lecture series,
the invisible gorilla experiment,
and in the invisible gorilla experiment,
there's two teams of players,
each with three members,
one dressed in black and the other
dressed in white,
and each team is passing the basketball
back and forth to the team members and
milling about.
You see a video of them doing so.
They've basically filled the video
screen and the white team is passing a
basketball to the white team.
Members in the block team is passing a
basketball to the black team members.
And your job as,
as far as the experimenter is concerned,
is for you to count the number of times
that the black black team,
yes,
black team passes the basketball back
and forth.
So that's what you do,
so now you have an ambition and a name
and a value and they ambition and the
aim and the value,
they're all the same thing and that is
to perform well at the task.
Now the thing that's so cool about this,
and this is really so cool,
it's just unbelievably.
It's just unbelievable that this is the
case.
It's like a complete validation of,
of a certain element of the Buddhist
worldview.
So they pass the ball for a couple of
minutes and then the experimenter says
to you,
how many?
And you say 15 and [inaudible] you're
happy and you're happy with yourself
because you've been paying attention.
And,
and the experimenter says,
yeah,
that's right.
Or maybe not.
Maybe you missed one.
And then the experimenter says,
did you see the gorilla?
And half of you say,
what?
What,
what gorilla?
Like really?
And he and the experimenter says yes.
And then he rewinds it and plays the
video.
And like a minute and a half into the
three minute video.
Sure enough,
in walks this guy in a gorilla suit,
six foot three or so stands in the
middle of the game,
right in the middle of the game,
the same size as the players,
perfectly obviously evident beats his
chest for like a second and a half and
then sorta saunders off and half the
people who watched the video don't see
the gorilla,
which is absolutely shocking,
and what that means is that your
ambitions blind you to the nature of
reality.
Now they eliminate some reality,
but they blind you to most of it and
that's fine because you're not.
There's not a lot of you.
In some ways,
you're very pinpoint thing like a laser
beam and so you just can't be attending
to everything all the time.
But one of the things that you might ask
yourself once you know that is that if
you're suffering dreadfully than one
possibility is that you're so fixed on
the point.
You're so fixed on a point.
The fact that you're so fixed on the
point that you're fixed on might be
integrally related to why things are
going so catastrophic it wrong.
Now perhaps not because you know there's
a lot of arbitrary ness about life and
perhaps you suffer even when you don't
deserve to.
That seems to happen in the book of Job
for example,
because job is a good guy and God has a
bet with Satan,
which seems like another relatively
nasty thing to do to let's say just
torture him and he does quite nicely to
see if he'll turn against God and it
seems like a rather playground sort of
thing for God to engage in.
But the point is is that even in a
document like the Old Testament,
there's ample suggestion that sometimes
people just get wiped out and hurt even
if they're living good moral lives,
aiming properly and all that.
There's an arbitrary this in life that's
not radical,
but it's possible that it's what you're
clinging to that's hurting you and it's
even possible.
That's the thing that you're clinging to
the hardest that's hurting you the most.
That could easily be someone you love.
Like lots of times I see people in
therapy and they're miserable for one
reason or another and sometimes it's
because they have a very close
relationship with a family member and
that just isn't working.
You know,
the family member for the sake of
simplicity we'll say is not really
oriented towards helping them have a
good life.
The family member is instead oriented
towards making them as bloody miserable
as you can possibly make anyone and and
what would you say?
Exploiting the bond between family
members in order to enable that and then
sometimes the sacrifice that's necessary
is either merely distancing yourself
from that person,
sometimes substantively and sometimes
seriously distancing yourself from like
we don't talk anymore ever and so that's
pretty damn rough and it hurts and all
of that,
but,
but
it's a good example of the fact that
sometimes in order to extract yourself
from the miserable bit of chaos that you
happen to be in meshed in.
You have to let go of what you love
best.
If the world you are seeing is not the
world you want,
therefore it's time to examine your
values.
That's really worth.
It's really worth thinking about,
you know,
because the alternative is to curse
fate,
right?
Because if it isn't you and there's
nothing you can do to change,
there isn't something you're doing
that's wrong.
Then it's fate itself.
It's the world itself.
It's other people let's say because
they're a huge part of the world or it's
the nature of the world itself or,
or it's God himself in whatever form you
either believe in or don't believe in
because it's fundamentally all the same
in this situation that I'm describing.
So.
And one of the things that's really
interesting and I mentioned this before
about the Israelites in the Old
Testament,
is that they got this right.
It's really something because what
happens to the Israelites over and over
in the Old Testament is that they get
all puffed up about how wonderful they
are and then they make moral errors
because they're arrogant and then God
comes along and just cuts them into
pieces for like generation after
generation and they wobble back to their
feet and they always maintain the same
attitude,
which is we did something wrong.
We did something wrong.
It's like it's like,
it's like an axiom rather than
observation is that if we're not,
if things are not laying themselves out
for us as they should be,
then we cannot curse God.
We have to look to ourselves while and
you think,
well,
why not curse?
God knows.
Maybe it's his fault.
That's a really good question and one of
the things that I've tried to figure out
over the last 30 years is,
well,
why not just curse God?
Because there is this arbitrary element
to existence and we are vulnerable and
there is plenty of suffering and things
are unfair,
like there's problems,
right?
There's injustice and unfairness and all
of these things and an endless
suffering,
so why not just laid at the feet of God
and the whether God exists or not.
In some sense,
by the way,
with regards to the metaphysics of this
particular discussion is not relevant.
It's the point remains the same either
way and the answer is as far as I can
tell that if you refuse to take on the
responsibility yourself and you
attempted to lay it at the feet of
either society or being itself,
then you instantly start to act in a way
that makes everything much worse,
not only for you but for everyone else
and maybe even for being itself and so
it's not helpful.
Now,
if you're.
If you decide that it's you,
you've got the problem,
maybe that's not even true,
like maybe you are someone who's being
tortured by the bet between God and
Satan and like too bad for you if that
happens to be the case,
but it still seems to be the appropriate
thing
for a human being who's standing on his
or her own two feet in a proper manner
to take the responsibility on for
themselves regardless of the counter
arguments that might be made against it.
That's really something.
It's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions.
I also think of that it's a deadwood
issue.
You know,
one of the things you see with motifs
like the pair of the Phoenix,
remember when Harry Potter goes off to
fight,
he's like St George.
He goes off to fight the hell.
Is that thing,
the bast list that turns you to stone?
When you look at it,
it's a dragon.
For all intents and purposes,
it's guarding.
Avert a virgin for.
What's her name?
For just not Virginia.
It's close to that though.
Ginny.
Ginny Ginevra,
right?
Which is a variant of virgin and very
introvert,
Virginia.
Well,
when he gets bitten by the,
by the dragon and poisoned,
that's the dragon of chaos,
right?
The thing that turns you to stone,
when you look at it,
when he gets bitten by it,
then he's going to die and yeah,
well,
if you get bitten by the thing that
turns you to stone when you look at it,
if it bites you,
man,
if you're not dead,
you're going to wish you are.
It's one of the two,
and then the phoenix flies in and cries
tears into the wound and that heals
them.
And the Phoenix is the thing that allows
the dead wood to burn off occasionally,
let's say.
Well,
it's,
I think it's once every hundred years
with the Phoenix and of course it's
pretty dramatic.
The whole damn bird has to go up in
flames and then there's nothing left but
an egg.
But there's a very serious message there
too,
which is that you can compare yourself
in some sense to a forest fire,
to a forest,
you know,
in a forest has to burn now.
And then for the deadwood to clear so
that the forest can actually maintain
its continued existence.
And if you stop the forest from burning
for a prolonged period of time,
which happened in the United States when
they were trying to manage the forest
fires too tightly,
then all that happens is the dead would
accumulate and accumulate and
accumulates and accumulates and
accumulates until the whole damn forest
is dead wood.
And then lightning hits it and it burned
so hot that it burns the topsoil off.
And then there's nothing left.
Nothing grows.
And so that's a good moral lesson,
which is don't wait too long to let the
dam did,
would burn off,
you know,
maybe a little self immolation on a
daily basis might be preferable to
burning yourself all the way down to the
bedrock,
you know,
once every 20 years or so.
Because maybe there won't be anything
left of you when you do that and you
know that happens to people all the
time.
I've seen that happen to people many,
many times.
The deadwood accumulates the mess around
them,
gathers the chaos that they haven't
dealt with accumulates.
And then one day the spark comes and
they burned so far and so fast that
there's not enough left of them to
recover.
And then they're the people who've been
eaten by the beast.
They are the people who've been eaten by
the Dragon.
And now we're inside its belly.
Another very common architectural motif.
And while maybe a hero will come along
and rescue them or maybe they'll just
stay in there forever.
And that's a precursor
to the idea of hell.
And it's not something I would
recommend.
So a little medicine on a regular basis
is a lot better too.
Then total emulation.
I'm on terms other than your own
sporadically.
It's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions.
There's another thing that
see in the Soviet Union went
solzhenitsyn,
wrote about the Soviet Union and its
pathologies.
It,
it sort of peaked in terms of it's
pathological authoritarianism when it
became illegal to complain that your
life wasn't going well and you just
think about how horrible that Esa.
Because because you know lots of times
you're isn't going well,
and I don't mean this in some casual
way.
I mean maybe,
I don't know,
maybe you have diabetes in your own.
Maybe you're gonna lose your feet or
something like it's really not.
It's nothing trivial that's going on
here.
Something is not good.
Or maybe it's economic or maybe you're
unemployed or,
and.
But you see the idea of the Soviet Union
was,
well,
we already have all the answers.
Everything's perfect already.
That's what totalitarians think.
Well,
if everything's perfect and you're
suffering,
then well maybe there's something wrong
with you because everything is perfect
after all.
And if you're a suffering then and what
are you gonna come out and say,
well,
I'm suffering.
It's like,
well then your evidence that things
aren't perfect,
right?
You're a widow or an orphan in an old
testament story,
you know when the Kings got too high and
mighty,
then they wouldn't pay enough attention
to the widows and the orphans,
and then the profit would come along and
say,
you know what?
Those widows and orphans a lot more
important than you think they are,
and if you don't pay attention to them
properly,
then things are going to fall apart
around you in a way that you just can't
even imagine and so well then you're
sort of like your own widow in your own
orphaned,
but you don't get to say,
hey look,
you know things aren't perfect yet
because I'm actually having still quite
a rough time here.
You don't get to admit to your own
suffering.
If you can't admit to your own
suffering,
then you certainly see the suffering,
especially the additional suffering.
The excess suffering should be treated
as evidence that you're not doing
something quite right yet.
It should be treated as evidence that
you're wrong.
There's something important that you're
doing that's wrong.
I understand how harsh that is,
and I'm not saying that everyone who is
suffering is suffering because they're
doing something in some simple way
that's wrong.
I was in an elevator once in a hospital.
It was a very terrifying thing and this
person got on who was just in an
absolute state of shock,
you know,
I mean,
it was really not good and I don't
remember how this happened,
but I engaged the person in conversation
and they just said that they had just
been diagnosed with what looked to be
terminal cancer.
And uh,
what was horrifying about it was that
what they were doing was going over life
in the elevator trying to figure out
what they had done in order to deserve
such a fate.
You know,
they immediately taken it on themselves
as a moral failing.
And that's not what I'm saying.
You can't come up to someone who has
cancer and say,
well,
if you weren't such a bloody idiot
throughout your whole life,
you wouldn't have cancer.
And believe me,
that happens a lot more than you think.
And people who have diseases like that
get blamed for it.
That's not what I'm saying.
It's not like that.
It's,
it's,
it's a more generalized attitude.
That is that if life isn't yet what it
should be,
then you have a response.
You have a primary responsibility to do
something about it,
and the place to start looking is to
your own errors and to fix them.
And that's.
And that's,
that's,
that's a safe bet man,
because you're probably doing some
things that you wouldn't have to be
doing that if you fixed would make
things better.
So it's time to let go and to sacrifice
who you are for who you could become.
There's an old story about how to catch
a monkey in case any of you are
interested in how to catch a monkey.
Now you're now you're going to know how
to do it.
First you have to take a large,
narrow neck jar just large enough in
diameter at the top for a monkey to put
his hand inside.
Then you have to fill it partway with
rocks.
So it's too heavy for the monkey to
carry,
then you scatter some treats near the
jar to attract them and you put some
inside inside the narrow neck jar.
A monkey will come along if you're lucky
and grabbed the goodies,
but he'll want the ones inside the jar
too.
So then put his hand in there and grab
what's in there.
And if you've set up your monkey trap
properly,
then he won't be able to get his hand
out because he's got the goodies.
Not Without unclenching his hand,
not without relinquishing what he
already has.
The monkey coucher can just walk over
and just pick up the monkey because the
monkey isn't into the whole sacrifice
thing because he's just a monkey,
you know?
And so you can catch him as a
consequence of his own.
An regulated hypothalamic desires to be.
What would you say,
charitable to the Monkey if you put out
candy or something like that.
So like how often does a monkey get
candy?
He's probably a little more motivated
than you are to not let go.
But you can get the point.
The monkey catcher can just walk over to
the jar and pick up the monkey.
The animal will not sacrifice the part
for the whole.
That's actually a pretty good phrase.
Hey,
it's the animal that will not sacrifice
the part for the whole.
Perhaps this story is apocryphal,
but as an eccentric psychology professor
once told me,
fiction lies to you in the most truth,
in the most truthful possible manner,
something valuable given up ensures
future prosperity,
something valuable,
sacrificed,
pleases the Lord.
Those are equivalent statements.
One's more articulated,
I would say.
That's the first statement,
and the second one is more dramatic and
more embedded in a collective religious
dream.
You might say,
what's most valuable and best
sacrificed?
Well,
obviously that depends on the culture
and the time.
What is it least emblematic of that?
A choice cut of meat.
Well,
if you're a herdsman,
for example,
that that's a big deal.
If,
I mean,
generally speaking,
throughout human history,
meat has been a very valuable commodity
as it is.
By the way,
among chimpanzees.
Chimpanzees hunt,
they like to hunt colobus monkeys and
you know they'll,
they'll basically start eating the damn
monkey lie.
They weigh about 40 pounds despite the
fact that the thing is screaming away
and that's pretty interesting because
one of the things that indicates is that
male monkeys that mail chimp's,
they're the ones that do the hunting,
aren't really inhibited that much when
they're in your mode by what you might
describe as empathy and there's certain
elements of human behavior that are
reminiscent of that.
You see that sort of thing have merged
now and then in human battlefields when
groups of men seem to abandoned all
internal regulation whatsoever to a
degree that makes you wonder if internal
regulation even exists.
Nice cut of meat,
well meets valuable.
You know,
and here's a good document by Richard
Wrangham.
I think while back a book about the
human invention of fire.
I think I told you a little bit about
this random claim that we invented,
fire or discovered fire mastered it
maybe two or 3 million years ago.
That's a long time longer than people
had thought and that that's what
actually transformed us physiologically
from our chimp,
like ancestors into the sort of spelt
creatures we are now because it's a lot
easier to digest cooked meat and meat is
a terminal,
the source of of nutrition,
energy,
raw materials,
all of that,
especially if it's cooked.
So me,
it's a big deal.
Cooked meat is a big deal and maybe it's
a choice cut of meat.
The
kindy might offer to a guest if you're
not A.
I always say this wrong.
Is it Vegan,
Vegan or Vegan?
I was Vegan,
but that's wrong.
That's a star.
Vegas a start,
right?
They're not like star creatures.
They're there anyway,
so you know,
you might offer that,
especially,
especially if a guest came to your abode
and you were heard,
man,
you might sacrifice a high end animal
and offer your guests a nice choice cut
of meat and that would actually matter.
It would mean something from the best
animal in a flock.
What's above even that?
Well,
in terms of the thing you could
sacrifice while your best animal.
That's good.
Well,
how about you?
How about your child,
Well,
that would be next on the hierarchy.
It's kind of hard to get past that.
Right,
and I think it's a.
it's a toss up whether the sacrifice is
greater.
If it's you or if it's your child.
I would say being a parent that is
greater if it's your child,
because I think most people who have
established
a
I hate,
I hesitate to say proper,
but I'm going to anyway.
He's a proper relationship with their
children.
It's if push came to shove,
they'd take the bullet and let their kid
go live.
The sacrifice of the mother is
exemplified profoundly by Michelangelo's
great sculpture.
The Ada.
Mary is Contemplating Her son crucified
in ruins,
so that's his body after he's being
crucified,
it's her fault.
It was through her.
He entered the great drama of being.
So what's the meaning of this sculpture?
It's a great sculpture.
It's just an absolutely unbelievable
sculpture.
You just can't believe that someone
could exist who could make something up.
Of course it wasn't the only thing
Michael Angelo made,
right?
It was like,
that's it.
It was something he just tossed off and
a couple of months while he was doing
other unbelievable things,
but you know,
it's,
it's an,
it's an object of contemplation,
which is why it's integrate cathedral,
integrate city.
It's an object of contemplation and the
ideas.
Something like what,
what,
what's the role of a mother if she's
awake.
I had a client come to see me a while
back,
not very long ago,
woman in about who's about 30 and trying
to make decisions about her life.
She was pretty career oriented and so I
asked her about,
although maybe having a bit of trouble
with their career.
I've seen this many,
many times,
so this is an amalgam.
This is a story that's an amalgam and I
talked to her about the other elements
of your life.
It's,
Oh,
you know,
there's only five things you do in life,
so you've got your career down,
know what do you do outside of your
career that's meaningful and engaging.
How are things going with your family?
Could be your family of origin,
your siblings,
whatever.
Do you have an intimate relationship and
like what's your plan for your own
family?
And apart from those five things there's
sort of something like get some exercise
now and then don't eat too badly and try
to stay away from the drugs,
you know,
that,
that kind of had an,
a crime that kind of lays out life and
if you miss any of those five things or
if you do any of those other things
wrong,
then you're in trouble and you can get
away with missing a couple of them,
but not all of them,
you know?
And she said something along the lines
of,
well,
I'm not sure I should bring a child into
this world.
And I thought,
Oh god Christ,
you got to come up with something better
than that.
Such a bloody cliche,
which is what I told her.
I said,
you know,
you must have thought that up when you
were 16.
It's like,
really?
That's your,
you can't do any better.
This was a very,
very smart woman.
It's like,
really?
You can't do any better than that.
It's like,
yes,
obviously this is a veil of tears and a,
you know,
a well of suffering and all of that.
If you asked 30 people who are wondering
about having children,
why they're wondering,
20 of them will say that and so that
that tells you how original it is.
It's not original at all.
It's not a thought.
It's like this little.
It's like a.
it's like a.
it's a meme.
It's something that lives in your mind.
It's not a thought and it's certainly
not something.
It's certainly not something that you
should just take it face value and say,
oh,
well I'm not having a family.
Then it's like,
no,
no.
You kind of look at that and you
criticize it a little bit.
It's like,
well,
the pop.
The other one,
that's the other one that's very common.
There's too many people on the planet
already.
It's like,
I really don't like that statement.
just who are you going to ask to leave?
Just how are you going to get them to
leave?
You know?
It's a serious question and who says
there's too many people?
What the Hell's wrong with people
anyways when we're running around
ruining the planet?
Yeah,
so like I think it was the club of Rome
who,
who prophesied by the way that there
would be so many people on the planet by
the year 2000,
that there would be widespread
starvation and they were completely and
utterly wrong about that and I think it
was the club of Rome who either compared
us to a virus or a cancer on the face of
the planet.
It's like,
oh,
really?
That's what you think about people a,
aren't you something?
Isn't that something to think about?
Human beings,
viruses and cancer.
What do you do with viruses and cancer?
Invite them in and make them at home.
It's like,
no,
you tried to eradicate them.
If you've got a bloody well watch your
metaphors folks,
because it isn't clear that you come up
with them or that they run you,
so you better watch him.
Thank you.
So anyways,
Mary and Mary's the great mother,
right?
That she's the mother.
That's what Mary is.
Whether she existed or not is not the
point.
She exists at least as a hyper reality.
She exists as the mother will.
What's the sacrifice of the mother?
Well,
that's easy if you're a mother and if
you're a mother who's worth her salt,
you offer your son to be destroyed by
the world.
That's what you do.
I mean,
that's what's going to happen,
right?
He's gonna be born and he's going to
suffer.
He's gonna have his trouble in life.
He's going to have his illnesses.
He's going to face his failures and
catastrophes and he's going to die.
That's what's going to happen,
and if you're awake,
you know that,
and then you say,
well,
perhaps he will live in a way that will
justify that and then you try to have
that happen and that's what makes you
worthy of a statue like that,
but still the sacrifice of the mother.
Is it right to bring a baby into this
terrible world?
Well,
every woman asked yourself that question
and some say no,
and they have the reasons Mary answers.
Yes.
Voluntarily.
Mary is the archetype of the woman who
answers yes to life voluntarily.
That's what that image means and not
because she's blind,
she knows what's going to happen and so
she's the archetypical representation of
the woman who says yes to life knowing
full well what,
what life is not naive,
not someone who got pregnant in the
backseat of the 1957 Chevy,
you know,
in one in a one night of,
of,
of half drunk idiocy.
Not that,
but consciously,
consciously knowing what's to come and
then also allows it to happen because
that's another thing that's a testament
to the courage of mothers.
My mother was good at this.
My mother's a very agreeable person too.
Agreeable for her own good,
but that's what happens if you're
agreeable because you're too agreeable
if for your own good.
That's the definition of agreeable and
so she's a nice person and still is.
Luckily she's still alive and we've had
a very good relationship and I have
always been able to make her laugh,
which is,
which is a good thing and but she was
tough cookie.
That woman,
you know,
if,
if I remember once she came across,
I was out playing in this baseball
diamond,
little diamond and empty lot really in
this little town I grew up in.
I was about 10 and she walked by.
I was there with a bunch of my friends
and I was about to have a fistfight with
his little tough kid that I hung around
with and there were half girls on the
team and the fistfight had some
relationship to status maneuvering,
you know,
in relationship to that.
Anyways,
we going to have a fight and my mum
walked by,
she took a look and I could see from her
demeanor that she knew exactly what was
about to happen and she looked for a
second and then she walked by and I
thought,
Whoa,
good work mom.
No kidding.
Hey.
It's like last bloody thing I needed at
that moment was for her to come charge
it up and say,
you boys aren't planning to have a
fight,
are you?
It's like,
well yeah,
mom,
where we're actually planning to have a
fight and now that you came and
intervened,
I actually lost before the God damn
thing even started.
So two thumbs up for mom.
She was also the person that said
because I had some trouble with my dad
when I was a key adolescent.
He had some trouble with me.
So you know,
it was 50 slash 50.
That's for now,
it's probably 70 slash 30 with me on the
70 end of the being the trouble.
And anyways,
I left home when I was about 17 and she
said something really interesting when I
left home.
She said it was too good at home.
You'd never leave.
I thought,
hey mom,
that's pretty good.
You know,
for,
for an agreeable person,
you've got a real spine man.
So that was pretty good.
So.
So you know,
a that says this.
The
mother is the person who also says,
get out there,
take your God damn lumps because you're
tough enough so that you can handle it.
She doesn't say you just stayed down
there in your bedroom bruiting away
because the world is unfair and treating
you badly and your suffering is too
much.
He says,
yeah,
there's a lot of suffering out there,
but you're a hell of a lot tougher than
you think you are.
So
in turn,
Mary's son Christ offers himself to God
so completely that is faith and trust in
the world is not broken by betrayal,
torture,
or death.
That's the model for the honorable man.
So when you have an interesting dynamic,
there you have the woman who's willing
to make the sacrifice,
lays the groundwork for the son who is
willing to make the sacrifice that works
out pretty nicely,
and it's a good thing to know and Christ
case.
However,
as he sacrifices himself,
God,
his father is simultaneously sacrificing
his son,
right?
That's one of the oddities of the
trinitarian model is that God sacrifices
himself to himself.
Same thing happens in norse mythology,
right?
Um,
is it norse Zeus,
Germanic mythology.
Zoo sacrifices himself to himself.
He actually hangs on a tree.
It's actually wounded in his side.
It's very interesting parallel,
but I think part of the idea is,
well,
the humanity,
the human race is trying to work out
well.
What's the ultimate sacrifice?
It's something like that ultimate
sacrifice,
a value.
Well,
the,
the passion story,
and I told you I was foreshadowing.
I'm bringing this into consideration.
Things we won't talk about for a long
time.
Maybe not at all in this lecture series.
I don't know because I don't know how
far I'll get is that,
well,
there's a supreme sacrifice demanded on
the part of the mother and there's a
supreme sacrifice demanded on the part
of the sun and there's a supreme
sacrifice demanded on the part of the
father all at the same time and then
that makes the supreme sacrifice
possible.
And hypothetically,
that's the one that renews.
That's the sacrifice that renews and
redeems.
It's a hell of an idea,
man.
And the thing about it is that I don't
know if it's true,
but I know that its opposite is false
and generally the opposite of something
that's false is true.
It's the opposite is false is because if
the mother doesn't make the sacrifice,
then you get the horrible eatable
situation or something like that in the
household,
which is just its own absolute
catastrophic hell,
and if you want a really good insight
into that,
I would say watch the documentary Crumb,
c,
r u,
m b,
a man that's been rated by some critics
has the best documentary ever made and
it is some piece of work,
man.
He does.
The only thing I've ever seen that
actually lays out the eatable
catastrophe in its full nightmare.
You
know,
so you could,
you could look at that.
So if the maternal sacrifice isn't
there,
then that doesn't work.
If the paternal sacrifice isn't there,
if the father isn't willing to put his
son out into the world,
let's say,
to be broken and betrayed and all of
those things,
then that's a nonstarter because the kid
doesn't grow up.
And then if the sun isn't willing to do
that,
well then who the hell is going to
shoulder the responsibility?
So if those three things don't happen,
then it's cataclysmic.
It's chaotic,
it's hell.
If they do happen,
is it the opposite of that?
While you could say,
well,
maybe it depends on the degree to which
they happen and and it's a continuum.
How thoroughly can they happen?
What we don't know?
Because you might say,
how good a job do you do have
encouraging your children to live in
truth?
Let's say,
well,
that's part of the answer to this
question and the answer likely is,
well not you don't do as good a job of
it as you could so it works out quite
well,
but you don't know how well it could
work if you did it really well are
spectacularly well or ultimately well or
something like that.
You don't know and you know people have
an intimation of this because one of the
things that's really cool about having a
young baby,
this is something you don't know until
you have.
There's two things you don't know.
There's a lot more than two.
There's three things you don't know
until you have a baby.
The one is that you didn't grow up yet
because you actually don't grow up until
someone else is more important than you.
You can't,
so people think they grow up if they
don't have children,
but they don't.
They just think they do.
Now there are some people who make
sacrifices of other sorts,
but this is a whole different ball of
wax as far as I'm concerned.
It's not a very elegant metaphor,
but you learn that it's kind of relief
relief not to be the center of
attention.
That's cool that you can sit back
because of course your child in your
family and in society is immediately the
center of attention and so unless you're
a narcissistic than you allow that to
happen and then you learn all sorts of
really good things about other people
because other people really like babies.
It's so cool.
I lived in Montreal when we had our
first child and I lived in a pretty
rough neighborhood by Montreal
standards.
Right.
It's like,
you know,
Montreal has such a great city like
Toronto.
It's like even the rough neighborhoods
are there more like charming with a
little dark under belly,
something like that,
but there were some rough characters in
our neighborhood and it was pretty poor
and we'd.
We'd push her around in her stroller and
these like grizzled rectal guys would
come by and they'd look at her and they
just light up and they'd come over and
like smile at her and you know,
he just saw there the positive element
of their humanity just.
Well,
fourth,
you have to be something seriously wrong
with you if you don't respond that way
to a baby,
you know,
I mean,
that's,
that's not good.
That's not good.
But it was so cool to see these
people.
You kind of give them generally you sort
of walk four feet around them on the
street,
you know,
and yet they were all of a sudden all
that,
the layers that were on them would just
fall off and they'd be so.
And the babies are sort of like public
property weirdly enough to sort of like
pregnant women,
you know,
because people often treat pregnant
women sort of like their public property
too.
I mean in a positive way.
Oh well Laura,
you're going to have a baby a.
well,
they do all sorts of cute things.
So.
So you know,
the reason I'm telling you that is
because there's a strong impulse in
people to note that there's something
miraculous about the existence of a new
human being and the miraculous element
is all the potential that's there,
right?
That's all there is.
There is potential.
And with every birth there is the
potential for something remarkable to be
introduced in the world.
And one of the things I've thought too
is the other thing you don't know is
that babies are generic until you have
one and then you're a baby isn't a
generic baby at all.
It's like instantly it's a person with
whom you have a relationship that's
closer perhaps than any relationship
that you've ever had and that you can
keep perfect,
right?
Because most of the relationships you've
had already or with people who are
screwed up and 50 different ways and so
are you.
But here you've got this baby and like
hair,
but it's not ruined yet.
And so you have this possibility of
maintaining this relationship that
starts out that baby really likes you.
And generally that continues for quite a
long time.
Is there are two years old and you come
home,
they're really happy to see.
It's kind of like having a puppy,
you know?
It's like they're thrilled when you come
home.
It's like how many people are thrilled
when you come home?
You know,
so I'll see you again.
It's like,
no,
not a little kid.
A little kid is thrilled when you come
home and you can keep that going.
And so there's this pristine element to
the potential relationship between
parents and children that's terribly
devalued in our society terribly.
It's almost as if were willfully blind
to it and I think it's an absolute
catastrophe because there's nothing.
There's very little in life that can
compare to establishing a proper
relationship with the child.
They make great company if you,
if you keep your relationship with them
pristine and so you know it's
worthwhile.
You think,
well,
so.
So the reason I'm telling you this is
because people look at infants and they
think they think this could be the
potential savior of mankind.
That is what they think.
That's how they act.
So that's what they think.
And the thing is,
it's also true now how true it is,
I don't know,
but that's I think probably because I
think it's probably because people don't
dare to find out how it's how it looks
to me in Christ case.
However,
as he sacrifices himself,
God,
his father is simultaneously sacrificing
his son.
It is for this reason that the Christian
sacrificial drama of Sun and self is
archetipal.
Nothing greater can be imagined.
That's why it's an architect.
You can't push past it.
So
that's the very definition of
archetypal.
That's the core of what constitutes
religious.
The greatest of all possible sacrifices,
his self and child of that,
there can be no doubt,
pain and suffering define the world of
that.
Equally.
There can be no doubt the person who
wants to alleviate suffering,
who wants to bring about the best of all
possible futures,
who wants to create heaven on earth,
will therefore sacrificed everything he
has to God to live in the truth.
So that's a page and half from the book
I'm going to release in January.
Thank you.
So back to genesis of we're all.
We already up to genesis four and Adam
knew eve,
his wife,
and she conceived
and Bare Cain and said,
I have gotten a man from the Lord.
Now this is after Adam and eve had been
chased out of the garden of Eden.
Right?
So what's really cool about this?
I really think that the atoms that can
enable stories,
the most profound story I've ever read,
especially given that it's.
You can tell it in 15 seconds,
I won't because I tend not to tell
stories in 15 seconds as you may have
noticed,
but,
but you can read the whole thing that
quickly and it's so densely packed that
I just can't.
It's,
it's A.
It's actually unbelievable to me that it
can be that densely packed.
Okay?
So the first thing is,
is that Adam and eve are not the first
two human beings can enable or the first
two human beings,
because Adam and eve were made by God
and they were born in paradise.
It's like what kind of cumin beings are
those?
You don't know any human beings like
that.
Human beings aren't born in paradise and
made by God.
Human beings are born of other human
beings,
right,
and so,
so that's the first thing,
and it's post-fall.
We're out in the world world in history
now.
We're not in some archetipal beyond,
although we are still to some degree,
not to the degree that was the case with
the story of Adam and eve.
We we've already been thrown out of the
garden,
were already self conscious.
We're already awake,
we're already covered.
We're already working.
We're full fledged human beings,
and so you have the first two human
beings can enable prototypical human
beings.
So what's cool is that humanity enters
history at the end of the story of Adam
and eve,
and then the architectural
patterns for human behavior are
instantaneously presented.
It's,
it's,
it's absolutely mind boggling and it's
not a great.
It's not a very nice story,
right?
So they're your brothers,
they're hostile brothers,
they've got their hands around each
other's throats,
so to speak,
or at least that's the case in one
direction.
So it's a,
it's a story.
The first two human beings engage in a
fratricidal struggle that ends in the
death of the best.
One of them.
That's the story of human beings in
history and that man,
if that doesn't give you nightmares,
you didn't understand the damn story.
Now in in these hostile brothers stories
which are very,
very common,
often the older brother Cain is used and
this is very true in the Bible,
but it's true in all sorts of folk tales
and all sorts of stories
of all sorts for that matter.
See,
the older brother has some advantages.
He's the older brother and in a
agricultural community,
the older brother generally inherited
the land,
not the younger brothers,
and the reason for that was is that,
well,
let's say you have like eight sons and
you have enough land to support a bit of
a family and you divided among your
eight sons than they have eight sons and
they divided among the eight sounds.
It's like soon everyone has a little
postage stamp that they can stand on and
starve to death on and so that just
doesn't work.
So you,
you,
you hand the land down in a piece to the
eldest son and that's just how it is.
It's tough luck for the rest of them,
but at least they know they're going to
have to go and make their own way.
It's not fair,
but there's no way of making it fair.
Well,
so the oldest son has some,
you might say he has an additional stake
in the stability and the stability of
the current hierarchy.
He has more of a stake in the status
quo,
so that makes them more of an emblematic
representative,
representative of the status quo and
perhaps more likely to be blind in it's
favor.
It's something like that,
so that motif creeps up very frequently
in the hostel.
Brothers archetipal struggle.
So Kane fits this.
The story of Cain and Abel fits this
pattern because Cain is the one who
won't budge who won't move.
He's stubborn.
Whereas the younger son who is able is
often the one who's more,
not so much of a revolutionary,
but perhaps more of a balance between
the revolutionary and the
traditionalist,
something like that.
Whereas the older son tends to be more
traditionalist authoritarian,
at least in these metaphorical
representations.
And Adam knew eve,
his wife,
and she conceived and Bare Cain and
said,
I have gotten a man from the Lord.
So there's the first human being cane.
It's like I told you that the
Mesopotamians thought that mankind
was made out of the blood of the worst
demon.
That the great goddess of chaos could
imagine.
Well,
the first human being is a murderer and
not only a murderer,
murder of his own brother.
And so,
you know,
Old Testament,
that's a hell of a harsh book and you
might think,
well maybe that's a little bit too much
to bear and then you might think,
yeah,
and maybe it's true too.
So that's something to think about.
I mean,
I,
human beings,
you know,
like they're amazing creatures and to
think about us as a plague on the planet
is its own kind of bloody catastrophe,
malevolent,
low genocidal metaphor.
But that doesn't mean that we're not
without our problems.
And the fact that this book that sets
sits at the cornerstone of our culture
would present the first man that was a
murder of his brother is something that
should really set you back on your
heels.
And again,
she bare his brother Abel and Abel was a
keeper of sheep,
but Cain was a tiller of the ground.
There you see a very old representation
there is able there and he's got his
sheep up on the altar and Cain is
bringing a Sheaf of wheat.
And I don't know exactly what's
happening here with the blood but or
it's a re perhaps it's something like
that.
But the overall impression of the images
that something transcendent is
communicating with this sacrifice.
And you see that.
So you think,
oh,
how primitive,
you know,
how primitive these people were
sacrificing to their god.
It's like,
you know,
those people weren't stupid and this is
not primitive.
Whatever it is,
it's not primitive.
It's sophisticated beyond belief.
Because the idea,
as I already pointed out,
is that you could sacrifice something of
value in that that would have
transcendent utility.
And that is by no means an
unsophisticated idea.
In fact,
it might be the greatest I did the human
beings ever came up with.
It's an answer to the problem that's put
forward in the story of Adam and Eve,
right?
Because we became self conscious and
then we discovered the future and then
we knew we were going to die and then we
knew we were vulnerable and then we
became ashamed and then we develop the
knowledge of good and evil.
And then we got thrown out of paradise.
It's like,
that's a big problem.
So what the hell are you going to do
about it?
While I will sacrifice,
that's the hypothesis.
Well,
that's a hell of a hypothesis,
man.
That's what we're doing.
You've made plenty of sacrifices even to
sit in this theater and many people may
plenty of sacrifices.
To have a theater like this exist in
many people made sacrifices so that we
can actually freely engage in the
dialogue that we're engaging in in a
theater like this.
And so it's like all of this is built on
sacrifice and sacrifice.
Bloody well better work because we do
not have a better idea sacrifice,
what's the counter position?
Murder and theft.
So let's go with sacrifice shall we,
and perhaps we won't consider it so damn
primitive,
you know,
because it's not so primitive.
And again she bare.
His brother Abel enabled was a keeper of
sheep and Cain was a tiller of the
ground.
Now some people have read into this
eternal battle between herdsmen and
agriculturalists,
which raged in the American West for
example,
because the herdsmen like to have their
herds,
sheep,
cattle go wherever they were going to
go.
And of course the agriculture,
the farmers like to have things fenced
off and so.
And the agriculturalists actually won in
the final analysis.
But anyways,
Abel is a keeper of sheep.
And that's interesting because that
makes them a shepherd.
And I think that's part of the critical
issue here because a shepherd.
I talked a little bit about shepherds
before.
You know,
if you look at Michelangelo Statue of
David,
of David,
which is another staggering work mean
that David,
he's no trivial figure and of course
steven do slight slays Goliath and
Goliath is like
the giant of the patriarchal enemy.
It's something like that and you know,
Middle Eastern shepherds,
they had to kick take care of sheep and
they're edible and the lambs are very
vulnerable and there were lots of wild
animals around.
It wasn't like England in the 16th
century.
It was like the reliance,
you know,
and you had a slingshot or a stick or
some damn thing.
And so your job was to keep the sheep
organized and not let them beat by the
lions alone.
And so you had to have a clue and be
tough and self reliant and all of those
things.
You have to be tough and self reliance.
You have to be able to take care of a
lot of vulnerable things,
able to do it on your own.
And so that's how are built into the
shepherd metaphor.
And it's,
you know,
it's a tough thing for.
It's not a great metaphor for modern
people because we tend to think of the
shepherd is someone like little Lord
Fauntleroy,
you know,
like some little,
certainly not a lion killing
hypermasculine lion killing monster
that's not a shepherd.
A shepherd sort of dances around and you
know,
it's not.
That's not the metaphor here.
That's,
that's,
that's not the metaphor here.
So Abel was a keeper of sheep,
but Cain was a tiller of the ground and
in the process of time it came to pass
that cain brought of the fruit of the
ground,
an offering unto the Lord.
Okay,
so he's participating in this
sacrificial ritual,
unable.
He brought of the firstlings of his
flock and of the fat thereof.
And the Lord had respect unto Abel and
to his offering.
Now you don't know why that is.
And this is a built in ambiguity.
I think now I think there's textual
hints,
but I'm not sure.
Okay.
Abel brought the firstlings of his flock
and of the fat thereof.
Okay,
so,
so what does that mean?
Well,
he brought high quite so high quality
sacrifice you don't know.
That enables sacrifices,
low quality.
Because it doesn't say,
you know,
Abel brought God some wilted lettuce and
then Burton,
he doesn't say that but,
but there isn't a sentence there that
talks about how high quality cane
sacrifices,
but in any case the Lord had respect
unto Abel and his offering.
So there's a hint that ables putting a
little bit more into the whole
sacrificial thing then then cane,
but there's also a hint that maybe God
is just like liking you a little better
than these likened him.
And that's I think useful from a
literary perspective because there is
that arbitrary ness about life,
you know,
with my own children,
for example,
one of them has had,
I would say
he
things come easy to him.
He's lucky,
fortunate,
however you want to put it.
He seems to be that sort of person.
Whereas my other child is like,
it's just like one horrible job,
like catastrophe after another.
And it's so strange to see that because
as far as I can tell,
there's the character.
Logical differences are certainly not
accounting for the,
for the,
for the difference in destiny.
You know,
my one,
the one child who's had so much trouble,
I mean as a child was just a wonderful
child,
so amazingly happy and easy to get along
with and fun and they have a terrible
time of it,
so who knows what God's up to,
but distributing fate equally certainly
isn't one of them,
and the Lord had respect unto Abel and
his offering,
but unto Cain and his offering he had
not respect and Cain was very wroth
angry.
Roth is a tough word and and these are
translated many times.
It's hard to get the full flavor of the
words,
but wroth and his countenance fell well.
To have your countenance fell at.
This is sort of up to fall,
is to,
to have it be heavy.
Depressed for sure.
Angry for sure.
Resentful.
Probably Roth.
That's anger.
So Kane is not happy clam that his hard
work is being rejected by God.
Now that's worth thinking about really,
because you think about how
human that story is.
You know,
you're out there.
Well,
we can say you might be useless
character and you know,
you're whining about how catastrophic
your life isn't.
It's pretty much obvious to everyone
around you and you that it's your fault.
You just don't try.
You don't wake up in the morning,
you don't get a job,
you don't engage in things.
You're cynical and you're bitter and
you're angry and you don't try to help
the people near you and you don't try to
fix up your own life and you don't take
care of yourself and you know,
and then things go wrong and it's like
hell freely.
What do you expect?
But then,
but that's,
I mean,
that doesn't mean someone in that
situation.
We'll just say,
well,
that's okay.
I deserve it.
Then there'll be happy about it.
They won't,
they'll be absolutely bitter about it
and angry.
But,
you know,
put that aside for a moment.
There are people who seem to struggle
very forthrightly,
let's say,
and still have one catastrophe after
another happen to them.
And so it's,
there's no easy answer in this,
in this story.
It's like you can fall,
fall afoul of God because your sacrifice
is our second rate.
Or you can just fall,
uh,
fall of God and you don't know why.
Well,
tough luck for you,
and then what happens in either case is
exactly this.
Almost inevitably
cain was wrong in his countenance fell
well.
You know,
you meet an I.
people like this,
right?
To me all the time,
I've seen many,
many of them as clients,
you know,
they say they're 20,
not so often.
30 more commonly,
sometimes 40.
Their lives haven't gone well,
you know,
they're in a pit of despair of one form
or another and not only are they in a
pit of despair,
but they're extraordinarily angry about
it and god only knows what they would do
with that anger if they had the
opportunity to give it full voice.
Right?
You know,
one of the things I've always thought
about Hitler is that,
you know,
people,
you have to admire Hitler.
That's the thing,
because he was an organizational genius.
You know the thing that doesn't stop
people from being Hitler.
The thing people don't.
People don't
refused the ambition to become Hitler
because they don't have the genocidal
motivation.
They don't follow that pathway because
they don't have the organizational
genius.
They've got the damn motivation.
And you know,
if you take 100 people randomly and you
talk to them and you really talked to
them,
you'll find that five percent of them
would take their vengeful thoughts
pretty damn far if they were just given
the opportunity and in fact they do
because they make life miserable for
themselves and often for their family
and sometimes for anybody they can come
near and then maybe another 20 percent
of people have that bubble up in them on
a pretty damn
regular basis.
So you can have some
the thief for cane.
If you don't have any sympathy for cane,
then you're not.
See Cain and Abel also,
they don't just represent to our
architectural types of being.
They represent
so it's not like you're a cane and
you're able to near cane and you're
able.
It's like you're half and half and your
half and half and your half and half at
something like this.
This is two different potential patterns
of destiny and you don't manifest one
purely in the other zero.
It's like you're.
It's like the line between good and evil
that runs down the human heart.
It's exactly the same idea and maybe
you're more like canes or maybe you're
more like Abel,
but there's still a little cane in you,
no matter how able you are and maybe
more than a little and probably more
than literally little,
and if you watch your fantasies,
which I would very much recommend you
will find that they
show you dark things about you that will
shock you if you allow yourself to be
conscious of what you're thinking.
So it's a good time when you're having
an argument with someone,
especially someone that you love,
to just watch the pictures that flash in
the back of your mind.
That's part of let's say coming into
contact with what Carl Jung called the
shadow and the shadow is the
manifestation of cane.
That's a perfect way of thinking about
it and one of the things that young said
about the shadow [inaudible] young was
not someone you mess around with
lightly.
He said,
human shadow has roots that reach all
the way to hell and young meant that
that's no metaphor for him.
Now he might not have meant it in the
same way that a fundamentalist Christian
from from the southern us might mean it,
but I would say that young men to in a
way that's far more terrifying and also
far more true so and Cain was very wroth
and his countenance fell,
so there's able burning is offering away
there at least in this sort of
relationship with,
let's call them the archetypical figure
of culture,
the archetypical father,
and it's something he respects.
That's the thing.
It's an indication that the postures and
the indication of respect
and then there's cane in the background
and you see his face is in shadow and
he's.
He's jealous of what's happening here
and he's going through the motions
perhaps and maybe God just doesn't like
them.
We don't know,
but he's going through the motions and
he's not very happy about it and you
know that that's actually a phrase that
you could.
You could carve into many people's
tombstones as an epitaph for their life,
which would be went through the motions
but wasn't very happy about it.
This is really an interesting one.
I think.
I mean,
so I don't know what God's doing here
exactly,
but he's helping ignite the sacrificial
flame and that's kind of an interesting
idea I think because you know,
let's say that you have an impulse to
make a sacrifice.
You think,
well,
I should change this about my life.
What?
What's like?
Where does that come from?
That impulse is just,
well just manifests itself out of
nothing.
So what word you came up with it?
Well,
you might want to stop thinking about
that thinking so surely that you come up
with your own thoughts.
You don't come up with your damn dreams,
do you?
They just happen and God only knows
where they come from.
They come from your brain.
Oh boy,
that's a sophisticated answer.
They come from your unconscious.
Well,
that's not much better.
At least it's somewhat better,
but there are those matt,
amazing dramas take place in the theater
of your imagination at night.
You don't even understand what they are
and yet they occur night after night and
those things,
dreams.
They can contain wisdom that it just,
well,
it just staggers the person who has the
dream.
Once they get the key to the dream,
once they remembered,
it's like,
oh look,
you just revealed a bunch of wisdom to
yourself that you didn't know what.
Where'd that come from?
Well,
you don't know.
How in the world can you dream up things
that you don't know.
That's a tough one.
Maybe we'll talk about that at some
point in this lecture series because
there are some reasonable things that
can be said about that,
but you know the idea of that
there's something that's not you.
You would call it the self.
Carl Jung would call it the self,
which he thought of it as the totality
of your being across time and space.
It's something like that and that you
know,
each second that you exist is a slice of
the self manifesting itself across time
and space and he thought of the self is
partly the voice of conscience.
Whatever that is that helps guide you
when you have to make a difficult
decision and a difficult decision might
be,
well,
what do I need to sacrifice?
What is,
how do I need to discipline myself?
Right?
What do I need to for go,
well,
how do you figure those things out?
Well,
you know,
we'll just picture is trying to put
forth the idea that perhaps if you would
establish the proper relationship with
God the father and we've talked about
what that might mean,
then he would help figure out how to get
this sacrificial fires burning so that
you could stay in a proper relationship
with him across time.
Well,
if that's such an unreasonable
proposition,
what's the alternative proposition?
Well,
this isn't working out very well,
that's for sure.
You know,
Kate seems to be doing it.
I don't know what it is.
It's like he says,
if he thinks he can only do it himself
or maybe he wants only to take credit
for it or something like that,
he's not in this
grateful,
let's say,
and inquiring grateful and inquiring
posture because
that's what a prayer for posture should
be.
It should be grateful and inquiring and
grateful is,
thank God things aren't worse for me
than they are,
and you shouldn't be grateful about that
because they could be a lot worse than
they are mad.
They can be so bad and inquiring would
be,
well,
I don't really know how I could make it
better,
but I'm.
I'm open to suggestions,
man,
if I can figure out how to do it all,
try it.
That's the.
That's the humility and the inquiry.
That's a humble inquiry.
How could I make things better?
It's something like that and that's what
sacrifices do I need to make in order to
make things better.
That's a good question to ask yourself.
You could ask yourself that every
morning,
what sacrifice do I have to make to make
things better?
You can decide what constitutes better.
How about that?
Then it's not even as if it's being
imposed on you come up with your own
notion of what constitutes better.
You know,
we try to make it sophisticated.
Should just be better for you because
that isn't going to work very well.
Right?
You're,
you're just gonna fall down stairs.
If you do that because you have to live
with other people and besides stupid
anyways,
what are you going to do like can't even
just nothing you could even say about
that.
It's so that that's the.
That's the attitude of a very badly
behaved hyper aggressive two year old
and I mean that technically and so you
could.
You could ask yourself,
well,
how I have this day that lays itself out
in front of me?
What thing could I let go of that's
impeding my progress that if I let go of
would make my life better,
my family's life better,
my culture is life better,
my being better,
and then that would give you something
to do for the day,
wouldn't it into justify your miserable
life because you need that.
That's the whole point of the first
story of Adam and eve.
What do you have?
A miserable life?
Okay,
what am I going to do about that?
Well,
if you just have a miserable life,
you're just going to suffer stupidly and
get bitter about it.
That's what happens to cane.
It's like,
well,
how about not doing that?
Because that seems to just take a bad
deal and make it worse.
How about making a sacrifice and seeing
if you can please God and put being on
track?
God,
that'd be something to do.
What could be better than that?
What could possibly be better than that?
Well,
that's why it's archetipal ban because
nothing's better than that.
That's where it tops out.
So when you can do that,
you could do that every day.
You'd have to do it in a little way
because like what good are you?
You know you're not going to go and
bring this socialist utopia and to being
in one fell swoop.
You might also think that one of the
things came mind figure out here.
There's a couple of things that just
aren't going right for him,
downwind of the fire,
not the right place to blow from,
and the fact that he's in hen galloped
in Hayes and smoke and breathing it in
and the fire isn't burning,
might be an indication that he's doing
something wrong or he could be wiping
his eyes and say,
Jesus,
what kind of stupid bloody universe
would produce smoke like this?
It's like,
yes,
well that's the more likely outcome,
and the Lord said unto Cain,
why Art Thou wroth and why is they
countenance fallen if they'll do as well
shalt thou not be accepted.
Now that's an interesting line because,
and I've looked at a variety of
different translations of.
This is seventh verse here,
like a bunch of them because the
translation for that,
that's a critical line and the
translation really matters and so I'll
tell you what I think the story is what
I've been able to figure out,
and I'm sure I haven't got it completely
right,
but it's
so he asks,
God says to him,
if you do well,
won't you be accepted?
There's a hint there,
right?
It's something like,
well,
things aren't going so well for you,
so the first thing you might think is
you're not doing well.
What does that mean?
You're not doing good?
Does that not mean you're not acting
properly means it's the hint because the
is suggesting that if you are doing
properly,
you would be
successful.
I had a friend at one point who was a
very bitter person and he had a bunch of
problems and some of them were self
inflicted and some of them were fate I
suppose,
and he had.
He was,
he had become very,
very destructive,
murderously,
destructive,
genocidally destructive.
I would say.
You could see it in his dreams and,
and he lived with me for awhile and I
knew him very well.
He was a friend of mine from the time I
was 12 until the time he committed
suicide when he was about 40 and when he
lived with me I was trying to help him
get on his feet,
which was why he had come to live with
me because he thought maybe I could help
him get up on his feet
and he could only take relatively low
level jobs.
You know,
like he had some mechanical ability,
didn't,
he didn't get educated.
Although he's a very,
very smart person.
He probably had an Iq of about 135 or
something like that.
He's very smart and so he was bitter too
because he hadn't educated themselves to
the level that is,
as you know,
it's intellectual,
abandoned.
So we had to take jobs that were beneath
him intellectually and he had a real.
He had that real intellectual arrogance,
you know,
because he was smart and really smart
people often come to believe that only
smart matters and if they're smart and
all that and all that matters is smart
and then the world isn't sort of laying
itself at their feet and they've been
terribly betrayed and,
and then they cling to their
intelligence,
which is more like a talent or a gift.
Like it's like it's an idol,
you know,
a false idol,
which is exactly what it is in a very
dangerous one.
And get cynical about the stupidity of
the world and the fact that there are
talents weren't properly recognized and
that's just not that helpful,
you know,
because smart is a good thing.
But I'll tell you,
if you don't use it properly,
it will devour you just like all
arbitrarily assigned.
Tell it right.
So you might have a talent,
but it's your friend.
If you use it properly and do misuse it,
it will be your enemy and maybe that's
how God keeps the cosmic scales
adjusted.
But anyhow,
my friend was a very smart person,
although not as smart as he thought he
was unfortunately and but he hadn't done
what would have been necessary with that
intelligence to make it manifest itself
properly in the world and that also
embittered him because he also knew that
there was more that he could have done
if he would have done it and perhaps
more that he could still do what I was
suggesting to him while he was living
with us because he was two levels from
homeless by that point was that he
should find a job that he could find
working in a garage,
working in a shop,
something like that because he had some
mechanical ability and that he should
do.
He should separate himself from the
arrogance that made him presume that
such a job would be beneath him.
Because at that point no job was beneath
him.
And,
but more importantly,
it's not so obvious that jobs are
beneath people.
You know,
because even if you're a,
even if imagine you have a job as a
checkout person in a,
in a grocery store,
you know,
as a fairly unskilled job,
you can be some miserable,
resentful,
horrid bastard doing that job.
Boy,
you know,
you can come in there and just exuding
resentment and bitterness and making
mistakes and making sure that every
customer that passes by you has a
slightly worse day than they need to
write and,
and you know,
pilfering time and perhaps pilfering
goods and being resentful about the
people who,
who gave you the position because they
are above you in the dominance hierarchy
and talking,
you know,
bad things.
Gossiping behind the back of your
coworkers is like,
you can take your menial position self
described and turn that into a very nice
little slice of hell.
That's for sure.
And you know,
you go into places like that.
I always think of the archetypical diner
in that way.
You know,
you guys have been in this diner.
There's a really good opposite diner and
there's a great video on youtube.
It's Tom waits reading,
reading a poem by Makowsky.
And I think it's called Nirvana and it's
about a good diner that he happened to
visit because he happened to visit when
he was on a bus when he was,
when he was a kid,
a diner where everything was going well.
And you could listen to that.
It's great.
I think it's great.
But this is the opposite diner I'm
thinking about.
So you'll go into a diner,
right?
It's 7:00
in the morning and you order some bacon
and eggs and some toast and then you
look around in the diner and you think
it was 1975 when the windows were last
washed and there's this kind of thick
coating of who gives a damn grease on
the walls,
you know,
and,
and the floor to has got that sort of
stickiness that you really have to work
out to develop over years,
you know,
and the waitress is,
she's not happy to be there and the guy
behind the counter isn't happy that,
that happens to be the waitress that
he's working with.
And then,
you know,
you walk down the stairs maybe to the
washroom and now it's its own little
trip and so you come back and you order
your damn eggs and your order,
your toast in the order your bacon,
and then it comes in like the eggs are
too cooked on the bottom.
So they're kind of brown and then
they're kind of raw on top and they're
called in the middle,
which is,
you really have to work their cooking an
egg like that man.
But you can master that with like 10
years of bitterness.
You teach how to cook an egg like that.
And then the toast,
here's what you do at the toast,
right?
You put,
you take,
you take the white bread,
you know the priestly based stuff that
no one should ever eat.
And then you put that in the toaster and
you overcook it and then you wait and
then you pop it out of the toaster.
And then because it's overcooked,
you scrape it off and you knock off the
crumbs so it doesn't look too bird.
And then you wait until it's cold and
then you put cold margin on it because
if you put cold,
first of all,
not butter,
but if you put cold margin or you can
also kind of tear holes in it so that
then it has lumps of margarine in it and
it's really dry except where it's too
greasy.
So that's like it's own little work of
art man.
And then you put that on the side with
the,
with the,
with the eggs and then you have the
potatoes and this is how you cook the
potatoes properly.
So their leftover potatoes and you keep
dumping new leftover potatoes into the
old leftover potatoes over weeks.
And so some of the potatoes,
if they're no longer potatoes,
right?
They've have returned to mother earth.
Then you flop them on the grill and you
sort of know,
you burden them a bit I guess.
And then you slap them on the plate and
Jesus,
you don't want to throw those man,
that's for sure.
And that's the point.
And then you have the bake and then you
want to make sure you buy the lowest
possible quality bacon.
Not that that's how you start and then
you throw it on the grill and you don't.
Your grill has to be overheated to do
this,
you have to cook the Bacon so that it's
raw in places and burned in other places
and it has that delightful.
Like older.
They'd only really cheap,
badly cooked bacon can provide or maybe
you use those little breakfast sausages
that no one in their bloody right mind
would let within 15 feet of anything
living,
you know,
and then you serve that right and you
serve it with the kind of orange juice
that is only orange in color and with
coffee,
that's.
What would you say it was started too
early in the morning.
That's the first thing.
Bad quality coffee started too early in
the morning.
God called once or twice.
It has been reheated and then you serve
that with whitener.
It's like,
here's your breakfast.
no man,
that's not breakfast.
That's Hell
No.
And you created it and then what you do
if you have a diner like that is because
you have a miserable life.
If you have a diner like that and you've
really worked on achieving that is every
night you go home and you curse your
wife and you curse your kids and you
fucking well curse God to for producing
a universe where a diner like yours is
allowed to exist and that's your bloody
life so well,
so that's what God's trying to point out
here is if thou shalt thou not be
accepted,
and if they'll do a snort,
well then sin lies at your door.
Well,
so what?
I looked at lots of translations for
this and actually the next line is an
unto these unto thee shall be his
desire.
Yes.
What God actually says.
It's something like this is like,
you know things aren't going so well for
you,
but if you were behaving properly they
would,
but instead,
this is what you've done.
Sin came to your door and send means to
pull your Arrow back into miss the
target.
Sin came to your door,
but he uses a metaphor and the metaphor
is something like sin came to your door
like this sexually aroused Cap Predator
thing and you invited to Dan first and
then you let it have its way with you.
It's like you entered into a creative.
He uses a sexual metaphor.
You entered into a creative exchange
with it and gave birth to something as a
consequence in that what you gave birth
to you,
that that's your life and and you knew
it.
Your self conscious.
After all,
you knew you were doing this and you
conspired with this thing to produce the
situation that you're in.
You said something about this,
similar about the Ed Mother's situation.
It was very politically incorrect.
What he said,
of course,
every single thing that you wrote was
politically incorrect,
so just how you could tell he was a
thinker by the way.
He talked about the unholy alliance
between hyper dependent children and
their mothers and he said,
well,
it's actually because you.
Freud thought about it as a,
as a maternal thing.
I'm not putting fried down.
Freud mapped out the whole situation
brilliantly.
I'm not putting four down,
but you know,
young was taking the ideas and expanding
them outward.
You know,
he said that there was an actually an
unholy alliance between a hyper
dependent child and uh,
and they need to pull over dependent
mother.
And the alliance was the mother would
always offer.
So maybe the kid is supposed to go off
and do something that would require a
little bit of courage and effort
and the mother says,
well,
are you sure you're feeling well enough
to do it?
And then the child could say yes
or the child could say no and then
he put in bed and
baby did all of that.
And.
But the thing is the child made the damn
decision to.
And you might think,
well that's pretty harsh,
but just because children are little
doesn't mean they're stupid and you
don't know children if you don't know
how children know how to manipulate
because they are staggeringly good at
that because they're studying you
nonstop trying to figure out a what
you're up to and B,
how they can get what they want in the
way that they wanted.
And so they can play a manipulative
game,
no problem,
especially if they're well schooled in
it.
And so it's sort of like that.
It's like maybe the mother is a little
too,
a little timid and a little inclined to
overprotect and maybe the child is
little manipulative and a little willing
to not take that courageous step out in
the world and to regress into infantiles
dependency instead.
And then you get a terrible dynamic
building across time that is like a
vicious circle,
you know,
or like a positive feedback loop.
It just expands and expands and expands
because sometimes in families you see a
hyper dependent child and a perfectly
independent child in st mother.
So obviously same author I mother is
very complex and mother for child a and
mother for child b are not the same
mother.
Even if they happen to be the same human
being.
That literature's quite clear on that,
but you get my point,
but God's idea was
not only are you not doing well because
you're not doing well,
but you're not doing well because you've
actually really spent a lot of work
figuring out how to not do well.
This is like creative effort on your
part and if you read about truly
malevolent people and you could start
with the columbine killers because they
left some very interesting diaries
behind,
so I would recommend them.
If you.
There's plenty of serial killers you
could read about in the people who've
really gone out and done dark things and
I've read more than my fair share of
that sort of thing and understand it
quite well.
If you really want to have your
countenance fall and be wroth 10 years
of brooding on your own catastrophe sort
of alone and letting your fantasies take
shape and and,
and egging them on and and allowing them
to flourish and let's say take
possession of you because that's exactly
the right way to think about it.
That'll get you somewhere like this and
there are more people who are like that.
Then you think and your more like that
than you think.
Well,
so Kane,
he's obviously not very happy about this
whole answer obviously,
because the last thing you want to hear,
if your life is turned into a
catastrophe and you take God to task for
creating a universe where that sort of
thing was allowed is that it's your own
damn fault and you should straighten up
and fly,
right,
so to speak,
and you shouldn't be complaining about
the nature of being,
but that is the answer he gets.
And so then what happens?
Well,
we have to infer that if cain was angry
before that,
he's a lot more angry now,
and of course that's exactly what the
story reveals,
and Cain talked with Abel,
his brother,
and it came to pass when they were in
the field that Cain rose up against
Abel,
his brother,
and slew him.
I'm going to read you something else
now.
This is foreshadowing again,
this is from the same chapter by the
way,
do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
Jesus was led into the wilderness
according to the story to be tempted by
the devil.
Matthew four,
one prior to his crucifixion,
this is the story of Cain restated
abstractly,
cane as far from happy as we have seen.
He's working hard or so,
he thinks,
but God is not pleased.
Meanwhile,
able is dancing away in the daisies.
His crops flourish.
Women love him.
First of all,
he's a pretty good guy.
Everyone knows it.
He deserves his good fortune.
All the more reason to hate him.
I used to joke when I.
I used to teach at Harvard now and then
my wife would have some of the
undergraduates over.
We used to joke afterwards because some
of them were very.
Many of them were very remarkable kids,
you know,
like they,
they were super smart.
They were athletic or they had some
dramatic ability or they were musicians
or they done some spectacular charitable
work because he basically to get
accepted into Harvard,
you had to be top of your damn school
and then you had to have at least two
other outstanding things going for you,
you know,
and what was so annoying about most of
these kids,
this was our joke,
was you really both liked them and
respected them.
It's like,
wow.
My joke was you'd think they would have
had the good graces to be like
dislikable sons of bitches,
at least with all the,
all those other great things going for
them.
They had to add like respectability and
likability to it as well.
So you thought,
well,
you know,
it really couldn't happen to a better
person.
It's like,
good God.
Well that's,
that's,
that's able to situation,
you know,
it's like,
and you know,
the funny thing too is that that's an
ideal.
That's the ideal,
right?
Because an ideal person,
let's say,
would be someone who you would want to
be like and someone who is operating in
the world like you would want to
operate.
And someone who fortune was smiling on
and someone who was making the right
sacrifices.
It's really what you would want to be.
And so cain kills that,
right?
So it's a psychological story too,
and you see this in the cynicism that
people have about people who have done
well in the world.
They're always looking for some reason
why they've done while they must be
crooked or they must be.
It must be conniving,
or they must be arrogant or they must be
psychopathic or and,
and of course all of those things exist,
but it's very bad trick to play on
yourself,
to make the proposition that the person
in the world who represents your own
ideal is that ideal because of
despicable reasons,
because what you do is train yourself
that the ideal that you should pursue
can only exist if it's motivated by
despicable reasons.
And then what?
Not only is Abel your brother,
dad as your brother in the field,
in reality,
but you've also slaughtered your own
ideal.
Well then what the hell are you going to
work for?
Well,
how are you going to live then?
bitterly and miserably.
That's for sure,
bitterly,
miserably and hopelessly.
That's how you're going to live and it's
so rare that I see,
especially publicly that people honestly
admit with sports figures,
they'll do it.
That's the one place where that seems to
happen,
but it's so uncommon for expressions of
admiration and gratitude to manifest
themselves in any public communication
of any sort.
Newspapers,
TV,
youtube,
twitter.
It's almost always
undermining and backbiting and criticism
and very often directed to people who
who have often done little else,
but bringing good things into the world
for other people,
and that's part of why this is such a
profound story.
He's a pretty good guy.
Everyone knows that.
He deserves his good fortune.
All the more reason to hate him,
that's for sure.
Cane bruise on his misfortune like a
vulture on an egg.
He enters the desert wilderness of his
own mind.
He obsesses over his ill fortune and
betrayal.
He nourishes his resentment.
Indulges in evermore elaborate fantasies
of revenge.
His arrogance grows to Luciferian
proportions.
I'm ill,
used and oppressed.
He thinks this is a stupid bloody
planet.
It can go to hell.
And with that,
he encountered
Satan in the Wilderness and falls prey
to his temptations,
and he does what he can.
And John Milton's unforgettable words to
confound the race of mankind in the
first route and mingle and involve earth
with hell done all to spite the great
creator.
He turns to evil,
to obtain what good forbade him.
And he does it voluntarily,
self consciously and with malice.
Let Him who has ears here.
So that's the first two human beings.
They're resentful,
bitter failure,
taking an ax to the admirable success.
And the Lord said Unto Cain,
where is Abel die brother?
And he said,
I know not am I my brother's keeper.
And
he said,
what has he done?
The Voice of your brother's blood crieth
unto me from the ground.
Okay,
now are they'll curse from the earth,
which has opened her mouth to receive
your brother's blood from your hand.
You know,
if you want to understand that,
which I would recommend,
he could read Dostoyevsky's
crime and punishment.
How it's a great,
it's a great novel.
I think it might be the greatest novel
ever written because I haven't read
every novel,
but in my experience it's the greatest
novel and it is exactly this.
It,
it,
it says what happens psychologically if
you commit the ultimate crime,
it's amazing.
It's absolutely amazing.
It's,
it's,
there's,
there's no psychologist like Dostoevsky
when now tell us the ground.
It shall not hence forth yield unto the
her strength of fugitive in a vagabond
shell.
There'll be in the earth and Cain said
unto the Lord,
my punishment is greater than I can
bear.
Now,
one of the things that's interesting
about this is that,
you know what?
I think the punishment that God lays on
cane is.
It's like the inevitable consequences of
keynes action.
It's something like that.
It's like,
well,
he killed his brother.
There's no going back from that man.
Like good luck.
Forgiving yourself for that.
Especially if he was an ideal,
especially if he was your ideal because
you haven't just killed your brother and
of course tortured your parents and the
rest of your family.
You've deprived the community of someone
who is upstanding and you did it for the
worst possible motivations.
It's like
there's no up from there,
right?
That's,
that's as close hell as you could manage
on earth,
I would say,
and Cain said unto the Lord,
my punishment is greater than I can
bear.
Behold,
thou has driven me out this day from the
face of the earth and from thy face
shall I be hid.
That too.
It's like there's also no turning back
to God,
let's say after an error like that
because well,
you've done everything you possibly
could to spite God,
assuming he exists and the probability
that you're going to be able to mend
that relationship in your now broken
state.
When you couldn't mend it to begin with
before you did something so terrible,
starts to move towards zero and it shall
come to pass that everyone that find it
to me shall slay me,
and the Lord said unto him there for
whosoever Slayeth,
Kelly Cain,
vengeance shall be taken on him.
Seven fold and the Lord said to mark
opponent cane list.
Any finding him should kill him.
That's an interesting thing.
I wondered about that for a long time
because you might think,
well why would god take cane under his
wing so to speak,
given what's already happened and I
think it has something to do with the
emergence of the idea that it was
necessary to prevent tit for tat revenge
slayings.
It's something like that,
you know,
and there's hints of that later in the
text because you know,
it's like,
well I kill your brother and then you
killed two of my brothers and then I
kill your whole family and then you kill
my whole town and then I kill your whole
country.
And then we blow up the world.
It's like,
that's probably not a very intelligent
solution to the initial problem.
Even though the initial problem,
which might be a murder is not an easy
thing to solve.
But I think it's something like that.
And then the last part of the story is
that's William Blake.
So Adam and eve have discovered their
dead son and Kane has become cognizant,
I would say,
of what he did and what he is.
Right?
So it's another entrance into a form of
self consciousness.
It's,
it's,
you know,
the self consciousness that Adam and eve
developed was painful enough.
They become aware of their own
vulnerability and their nakedness and
perhaps even their capacity for evil,
but cain becomes aware of his
voluntary engagement with evil itself
and sees that as a crucial human
capability.
And that's something modern people,
you know,
it's no wonder we don't take it
seriously like I know in the academy,
in and among intellectual circles for
decades,
the idea of evil has been like,
what are you medieval or something,
you know,
the whole idea of evil.
You don't.
That's a nonstarter as an intellectual
starting place as a,
as a topic.
And that's something that I've just been
unable to understand because I cannot
understand how you could possibly have
more than a cursory knowledge of the
history of the 20th century.
Much,
much less a deep knowledge of the
history of the 20th century and to walk
away with any other conclusion then well
good might not exist but evil.
Hey,
the evidence for that is so overwhelming
that that only willful blindness could
possibly explain denying its existence,
and that was actually a useful little
discovery for me because I also
concluded perhaps that if it was true,
evil existed,
then it was true by inference that it's
opposite existed because the opposite of
evil.
Let's say the evil of the concentration
camp,
let's say,
or we could get more specific about it.
We could say there's this one thing that
used to happen in Auschwitz where they
would take people off the incoming
trains.
Those who lived that weren't stacked
around the outside of the train train
cars and froze to death because it was
too cold.
You know those who only had to be stuck
in the middle where it was warm enough
so that maybe the old people died
because they suffocated,
but at least some of them were alive
when they made it to Auschwitz and then
they took those poor people out.
One of the tricks that the guards used
to play on them was to have the,
the newly arrived prisoners hoist like
100 pound sacks of wet salt and carry
them from one side of the compound and
these compounds were big.
This was a city.
It wasn't like a gymnasium.
It was like a city.
There were tens of thousands of people
there.
They'd have them carry the sack of salt
from one side of the compound to the
other and then back.
Right,
and that was to make a mockery out of
the notion that work would set you free.
It's like,
no,
you work here,
but there's nothing productive about it.
The whole point,
it's exactly the opposite of sacrifice.
In some sense.
It's so we're going to make you act out
working,
but all it will do is speed your demise
and maybe we can decorate it up a little
bit because not only will it speed up
your demise,
it will do it in a very painful way
while simultaneously increasing the
probability that other people's demises
will be painful and sped up.
It's a work of art,
that's for sure.
And to to to know about that sort of
thing and not to not regard it as evil
means while you can figure out what it
means for yourself and Kane wind out
from the presence of the Lord and dwelt
in the land of nod on the east of Eden
and Cain knew his wife and she
conceived,
you know,
in one of the critics that criticism is
a fairly common criticism of these
biblical stories as well.
If cain and Abel were the only two
people and from Adam and eve,
it's like,
where did all these other people come
from?
And doesn't that make the story like
simple minded?
It's like,
no,
that makes the reader simple minded.
I mean really that's the best criticism
of this.
You're going to come up with being.
You might say,
Oh,
you missed the point that that would be
the right response.
You missed the point.
And cain knew his wife and she conceived
and Bare Enoch and he built it,
the city.
And so it's cane that builds the cities
and starts the civilization and called.
That's pretty rough too,
right?
So it's the first fratricidal murderer
who builds the cities after the name of
his son,
Enoch,
and onto enoch was born Erad,
et Cetera,
going through the generations.
And lamach took unto him two wives.
The name of the one was done in the name
of the other Zilla.
So this is,
uh,
an attempt to flesh out the genealogy
and to describe how culture started in
some sense and these tribal communities
and Ada rebel,
and he was the father of such as dwell
in tents and have such as have cattle.
And his brother's name was Jubal and he
was the father of all is such handle the
heart bend,
Oregon,
and Zillah.
She also bear Tubal,
an instructor of error.
Every artificer and brass and iron and
Tubal cane traditionally is the first
person who makes weapons of war.
And lamech back to Mac.
Descendant of Cain said unto his wives,
Ada and Zillah hear my voice.
See Wives of Lamech Hearken unto my
speech for I have slain a man to my
wounding and a young man to my hurt.
If cane be avenged,
sevenfold truly lamach 77.
Well,
what I see in that is this proclivity of
this murderous capacity of cane as it
manifests itself as society develops to
to a murderous intent that transcends
the mere killing of a brother.
You hurt me,
I hurt you back.
It's no you heard me,
I,
I kill you,
and six other people and that thing that
happens after that is to not make it
seven people,
but to make it 70 people.
And so there's this idea that once that
that first murderous seed is sown,
it has this proclivity to manifest
itself exponentially and that's a
warning and that's also why I think
Tubal Kane who was one of keynes
descendants was the first person who
made weapons of war and that's pretty
much the story of Cain and Abel and it's
a hell of a story as far as I can tell,
and I think it's worth thinking about
pretty much forever because
there are so many.
It's so many.
It has so many facets,
you know,
and I think the most usefully revealing
of those facets is the potential for
this story.
Once understood,
to shed light on not your own failure.
Not even on your rejection by being,
let's say,
but by the but on the proclivity to
murder the best and the best in you for
revenge upon that violation,
because what that means and we know that
knowledge of good and evil into the
world,
so to speak,
with Adam and Eve's transgression,
is that now not only does humanity have
to contend with tragedy and suffering
and even the unharvested fruits of
proper sacrifice,
but with the introduction of real
malevolence into the world,
so there's the fall into history and
then there's the discovery of sacrifice
as a medication for the fall and then
there's a counter position which is the
emergence of malevolence as the enemy of
proper sacrifice and that's where we're
left at the end of Cain and Abel and
that's the end of that lecture.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay.
So you've said that one of your moral
axioms is that pain is bad and so we
should work to eliminate unnecessary
suffering.
Isn't this the basis for a secular
morality like utilitarianism and can we
therefore be moral without religion?
Well,
I don't think that it's.
First of all,
probably two,
the first question,
but that's also that derivation is
predicated on the idea that that's the
only idea you know,
that I'm putting forward as our ethical
idea and it's not.
If that was the only idea,
well then you could derive from that if
fairly straightforward brand of utility
utilitarianism,
but then also I think to push the
argument in that direction also
necessitates that reduction of what
might constitute pain to something to
unidimensional because I think suffering
is a better term than pain.
All the pain in some senses at the core
of suffering,
suffering is a multidimensional
phenomena and I don't think that you can
draw a simple utilitarian argument from
that.
Either the existence of suffering or the
observation that it's the reduction of
unnecessary suffering might be a good
thing.
So I'm also leery of those c,
it's not reasonable in some sense to
reduce a complex set of ideas to a
single proposition and then say the
ideas that I've been putting forward and
then to reduce another complex
philosophical set of ideas to a single
proposition and then say aren't those
two things the same?
And they are to reduce them to the two
simple axioms,
or you could argue that they're the same
but.
But you.
But I would say there's a tremendous
amount left out in the telling and that
what's left out is relevant.
It kind of reminds me of those.
It was philosophical games that
psychologists often play.
It's like,
well,
if there was,
I think one of.
What's the one,
I don't know if I can recall this
properly.
It's the trolley cart problem.
Something like,
you know,
if there was a train that was out of
control and it was going towards six
people on one track,
would you flip a switch?
So it's switched tracks and only killed
one person.
Would you do that?
And I read a question like that and I
think that's a stupid question.
And the reason I think that is because
you can't take a situation like that and
render it properly by reducing it to
that question.
And then you also can't assume that the
person who answers that question would
in fact act in the way they answered.
You can't presume any of that.
It's like because in a situation like
that in a high stress situation like
that,
the devil is in the details and I've
dealt with situations like that a number
of times and know perfectly well that
the devil's in the details,
so I think that there's a.
there's an intellectual reduction to
make a philosophical point that doesn't
give the complexity of the topic justice
and then there was a second part to that
which was and therefore can't we be
moral without religion?
Well,
I would say that question also suffers
in some sense from the same problem of
formulation.
I I'm very hesitant ever to answer a
question of the form is a merely a
manifestation of be when and b are very
complex things because the answer to
that is it depends on what you mean by
moral and what you mean by religious.
Because see there's an underlying
intellectual maneuver in a question like
that and the underlying maneuver is the
a priori assumption that something as
complex as religion or as complex as
morality can be reduced to an object
with a name and then two objects reduced
to their name can be assessed
simultaneously.
And I don't think that that's the case.
I think you can say something like,
is a triangle a square?
I think you can say that,
but I don't think you can say is it
possible to have morality without
religion?
I don't think you can have that question
because it has to be expanded out.
So it's like,
what do you mean by morality exactly.
And what do you mean by religion?
Because maybe and maybe not.
And so
and so the answer to that question is
decomposed the question.
Yeah.
I don't want my young children
indoctrinated with dangerous ideas.
Um,
and as time marches on,
I trust public education less and less.
I know that you have strong thoughts on
the danger of the devouring oedipal
mother who harms your child by
protecting them.
Um,
and that's certainly not what I aspire
to.
I wonder if in spite of your idea that
kids need to become tough and learn to
slay dragons,
if you have anything good to say about
the idea of homeschooling.
Well,
I don't have anything bad to say about
it.
I do know that the government has
recently taken moves to make it much
more difficult for people to homeschool
their children and it's not like five
years.
I mean,
15 years ago I would have presumed that
the vast majority of people who are home
schooling their children were to be
viewed with skepticism.
Initially.
I'm not so sure about that anymore.
Um,
you know,
for example,
I was sent a poster today.
Someone sent me this link that they
found in the local junior high school
and one of the media pieces that were
recommended on this poster was a movie
called Hedwig and the angry inch now
already thought that was a terrible
movie even though I'm perfectly capable
of enjoying bizarre movies,
but.
So it's a bizarre movie,
that's for sure.
But I also thought it was a terrible
bitter movie.
Terrible
and bitter.
Those are separate.
A movie can be bitter and be quite
great,
but it was a terrible movie and it was a
bitter movie,
but I can tell you one bloody thing
about that movie.
It's not required viewing for 12 year
old kids,
that's for sure.
So I think you have increasing reason to
be skeptical of the public education
system.
I also looked at the Elementary Teachers
Federation of Ontario's guidelines for
education from kindergarten to grade
eight and what that is in essence,
and I think I will do a video about it
in the relatively near future,
is a blueprint for transforming children
into social justice warriors had
basically says that it's like you don't
have to be a conspiracy theory to read
that.
I mean we have social justice tribunals
in Ontario and so the idea is,
well,
if you're going to get your children,
if you're going to get people to,
what would you say favor,
equity properly will then you better
start teaching them while they're young.
It's like maybe not.
So now you.
You asked that question properly because
you say,
well to terrible education system,
the wonderful mother homeschooling,
right?
That's the danger.
It's like,
no because it might not be the wonderful
mother homeschooling,
it might be the pathological mother
using the pathology of the education
system as an excuse to get her talons
into her children.
Right?
Because that certainly equally possible
or perhaps even more possible because at
least in the public education system,
there's some necessity for consensus.
So that's something that you have to be
very aware of and work to prevent.
Right.
And so I would say if you're going to do
that,
probably best not to do it on your own
and you need.
It's like you need a board of advisors
or something like that and so maybe it
can't just be you and you have to figure
out,
well what,
what is they aim and how are you going
to manage that and what makes you think
you can do it even if it's being done
badly publicly,
what makes you think you could do it
better?
I mean,
my general advice is,
and people have asked me this,
in fact,
I had a conversation with the guy who
was tiling my backyard this morning
about something his son had said to him
that he was taught at school recently,
which really made the tyler who had come
from a rather authoritarian country,
step back on his heels and think,
I'm not so sure I should be sending my
kid to public school anymore and maybe I
shouldn't be living in Toronto even you
know,
but my general advice is keep an eye on
your kids and discuss with them what
they're learning and and help equip them
with the tools to not only to articulate
their own viewpoint in response to what
they're being taught.
Now the problem is you might not have
the time nor the ability to do that.
That's no simple thing and increasingly
if you're unwilling to have your
children participate in what is
increasingly indoctrination and not
education,
thanks to in no small part to the
Ontario Institute of the studies on
Education,
which is an institution that I
particularly despise.
Because I think that all it does is
almost all it does now is produce
indoctrinate of children.
It's not an easy,
it's not an easily easy problem to
solve,
so more more power to you wanting to
put your children in a situation where
they're not being indoctrinated,
but the alternative is very,
very complicated and difficult.
So yeah.
Thank you.
I was wondering,
is likely,
you know,
I would say generally speaking,
there's a shamonic basis,
two to almost old the religious
traditions because that's the mill you
out of which the religious traditions
emerged.
Now I can't say much more than that
because I don't know and no one does
that.
The particularities.
I mean you might say,
well,
is there an illusion to the ingestion of
psychoactive chemicals in the Adam and
Eve story?
And people have made that case and
there's been powerful cases made.
So there's a book,
for example,
I think it's called Soma by a guy named
Gordon West Saul,
who was the first person,
an amateur psychologist who was the
first person to propose that the Soma of
the Hindus was we're at emoney to
miscarry mushrooms,
which is actually a.
those are the red mushrooms with the
white dots that you always see on fairy
tales.
You know the cute ones,
toadstools flies like to eat them.
They're called fly a garrick.
Also lie seem to like getting stoned.
I know that's weird.
I know that's weird thing to say,
but there's a good book on animal use of
psychedelics and more animals use them
then you might think.
But anyways,
there is some evidence that you know of
use of,
of the ingest node,
let's say metaphorically speaking as an
aid to the transformation of
consciousness that goes back so far that
well forever as far as human beings are
concerned.
But to specifically tie that to the Adam
and Eve story,
I haven't been able to see any evidence
that would definitively linkedin.
You know,
there's,
there's been a lot of interesting books
written about that.
There's one that was quite a kind of a
weird hit and I think in the early,
late sixties might've been early
seventies.
It sort of got brushed off as a hippie
book,
but it really wasn't.
It's called the sacred mushroom and the
cross.
That's really,
that's the sort of book you read and you
think,
Huh?
I don't know.
I don't know what to do about that.
I have no idea what to do about that
look.
So that's all I can say about that.
Yup.
My is about martyrdom.
So,
um,
what do you think murdered him or the
willingness to suffer and die for what
you believe,
if anything says of the convictions and
what do you think is the benefit for the
murder which is at least traditionally
in immaterial and transcendent?
Good compared to the regular sacrifice
or practical sacrifice which is ordered
to the future material,
psychological or economic good
man.
You guys really come up with some wicked
question.
I think it depends to some degree on how
you define martyrdom.
You know,
cause you could,
you could define a dose.
Okay.
The tendency to pathologically self
aggrandize yourself on public display,
or you could say it's the decision to be
immovable about a set of principles.
Right.
So let's go with that one.
Forget about the first one.
Well,
I wouldn't recommend it to anyone.
Right.
Get in some sense.
It's,
it's.
Hmm.
That's a really tough one.
People asked me.
I'll make it personal.
I suppose people asked me when I first
got involved in all this political
controversy back in September,
October.
Well,
they asked me a couple of things.
They,
they asked me if this was the hill that
I really would choose to die on,
like pronouns and the transgender issue.
Yeah.
Well it's not what I want.
I would have picked and.
But I mean it was about language,
you know,
and that,
that makes it nontrivial.
And Bill [inaudible] was passed this
week as you know,
when.
One of the things that was quite
interesting about that,
and I will answer your question,
was that Brenda Cossman,
who was the woman that I debated,
I think it's
one of the persons that I debate.
It didn't like to be referred to as a
woman,
but I didn't think it was Brenda.
Anyways,
she wrote an ipad and I believe it was
in the globe and Mail,
but it might've been the national post
saying as I knew,
she would say that bill [inaudible] was
just the beginning.
We have plenty of work left to do and
yes you can bloody well be sure that we
have plenty of work left to do.
Anyways.
I was asked during that period of time
whether or not I was being a martyr,
you know,
and I thought,
well it's not really one of my
ambitions.
You know,
it's like that sort of torn to the lions
thing doesn't sound like exactly
something you might aim for.
But I think,
well sometimes you find out in your life
may be that there's something you won't
do and one thing and then maybe you just
don't do it no matter what the
consequences.
Maybe how I don't know because you know,
I haven't been pushed to that point,
but there have been people who have been
pushed to that point in history and they
basically said,
I don't care why you do to me,
I'm not doing that,
and you know,
maybe some of them were suicidal and
some of them are psychotic and some of
them had whatever other problems that
people might have,
but yeah,
I do have this suspicion now and then
some of them were just kind of serious
about saying no and there's some utility
in being serious about saying no and
that sort of revealed itself to me,
I suppose to some degree,
back in September when I read a piece of
legislation that said I would have to
use some words that were legislated by
the government and I thought,
there's no god damn way.
I'm going to do that under any
conditions that I can imagine.
Now.
There are conditions and I have a pretty
good imagination for unimaginable
conditions.
I couldn't see it because I thought that
if I did that I would break through
whatever would be left of me after
having done that would no longer be me
and
I'm not interested in that.
I know what that would be like.
I actually do know what that would be
like and I'm not interested in that.
I would rather have whatever else
happens happens and people have said to
me,
well,
you're so courageous for taking this
stand.
It's like,
yeah,
well I'm not going to claim any sort of
other world courage.
I can tell you that,
but I can see,
but one thing I do know the difference
between these different forms of hell,
let's put it that way and there's the
hell that maybe I might be dragged
through if I don't
agree,
don't act in accordance with this law
and there's the hell that I would be
dragged through if I did act in
accordance with the law and I would
vastly prefer the first hell to the
second,
and the isn't clear to me that that
actually constitutes courage.
Is it useful?
Because that's also the question about
martyrdom.
I think it's very useful for people to
see that someone will say there's no
way,
there's no conceivable way that you can
get me to do that,
and,
and I've thought long and hard about
such things too because I've taught very
many people to negotiate and one of the
things I always teach them is you don't
know,
you negotiate from a position of
weakness because you lose.
And so if I say no to something and I
mean no,
I mean no,
I bloody well won't do it.
And I think that if there are people who
also agreed that such things aren't
appropriate to have the example of
someone who says no and means it
actually turns out to be useful and so
then I would say,
well that's an inclination in the
potential direction of martyrdom and but
I don't see how to distinguish that from
actually just having the courage of your
convictions.
And so sometimes you might say,
well,
a person who has sufficient courage in
their convictions will sometimes be put
to death.
Well,
if that's the definition of a martyr,
then sometimes,
but not all,
always.
That's a really good thing and one of
the things I really liked about Social
Nixon's book,
the Gulag Archipelago,
which is an I refer to it often,
is an absolutely staggering book,
is that he put in many,
many stories of people who were in the
Gulag and they were often religious
believers,
which was a shock to him because he was
an atheistic communist.
When when he first entered the camps,
they were often religious believers and
they were people who said no.
There were things they would not do.
They would not participate in what the
regime was asking them to do and he.
You have to read it because the devil's
in the stories,
right?
The details in the stories,
but soldier Nixon in the camps grew to
have tremendous admiration for such
people and actually viewed them as
exemplars of the mode of being that was
necessary for him to escape both the
communist propaganda that had shaped him
as an individual and also the terrible
bitterness and sorrow and anger that he
experienced as a consequence of being
flung into the terrible concentration
camp conditions of the Gulag
archipelago.
So
Yep.
Hey Doc.
Thanks for staying alive and potentially
saving humanity.
So yeah,
that's good stuff.
Uh,
wondering about a couple of things.
Firstly,
who won that childhood fight?
Yukata.
Let that,
let that just slide.
So I'm thinking it's a big l.
well,
I can tell you because he was a tough
little kid.
See,
I don't remember what happened,
but my,
my remembrance of him was that he could
eat,
pound me out pretty pretty effectively.
So,
uh,
yeah,
yeah.
His name was vernon switching enoch.
Yeah.
He was a really good friend of mine and
I think,
I think Vernon's still lives in
fairview.
So if,
if,
uh,
if he hears of this then maybe he'll
remember that too.
And,
and uh,
uh,
you know,
so probably he would have won.
I didn't win that many physical fights
when I was a kid.
So.
Okay.
That's not the only questions anyway.
Cool.
Uh,
I'm not sure if you've,
if you've actually been asked this
before,
I've missed the last two lectures,
but I'm wondering what your thoughts are
on,
on token jr token and uh,
his work,
not just lord of the rings,
but the silmarillion,
which is basically like I'm,
I'm seeing all this and I'm thinking
it's like the modern Bible in a way.
It's got the weird names like to ball
cane and all that stuff.
And then specifically when were talking
about Caine just now and how he was
things just moving and when he was
talking about,
uh,
how he felt like betrayed by God and he
spent his whole life working a,
it's a spite him essentially.
And he kind of set the path for,
for the darkness in humanity that's
almost exactly melcor which was in the
similar really.
And basically what's would spawn
everything evil in middle earth and more
door and whatnot.
And I don't even know as much as go on
talking.
Was it a student of mythology and you
know,
the,
um,
uh,
the story of the Hobbit is a retelling
of Beowulf in large part.
And that's a dragon slaying myth.
And and so the,
the reason that Tolkien and rolling for
that matter are so popular is because
they've done a very good job of making
the old myths new and,
and well,
look what's happened with the marvel
series.
It's the same thing with star wars and
all of that is that you can't not
respond to these stories.
Now you're gonna find them in one form
or another in sometimes well with the
biblical stories.
For example,
the mythological,
the meaning of the mythological content
has become invisible.
That's partly the death of God that
Nisha was referring to,
but that doesn't mean that the stories
themselves vanished because people have
an eternal hunger for them.
Now,
the problem with them emerging in let's
say,
more literary or less sophisticated
form,
let's take the marvel movies as an
example,
is that they're not surrounded by an
articulated culture the same way the
biblical stories are.
So for example,
they're not surrounded by something like
paradise lost by John Milton,
which or,
or Dante,
oh,
inferno,
which are works of ill,
unlimited depth.
And so you throw away something of great
value and reacquire it in a different
place with less value perhaps,
but more comprehensive ability.
It's not a,
it's not a great trait that is not a
critique of talking and it's not a
critique of anybody who's drawing on
mythological stories for their
narratives.
You have to do that to be a good
storyteller.
But it's nice to go as close to the
source as you can as well.
So.
Yep.
And the overlaps that you described
while.
Yeah,
it's exactly what you'd expect because
if you deal with great mythological
themes,
you start to get the archetypes are at
the bottom of stories.
And so if,
if the story goes down far enough,
it runs into the archetypes.
And that was the youngest claim.
And I think he got that exactly right.
So,
okay,
last one,
uh,
there's a passage in paradise lost were
the demons are building pandemonium
under mammon's sort of guidance and they
crack open the what's not really earth
but hell.
And they take out the gold and they
build pandemonium,
which is the most sophisticated
architectural wonder of all time in,
in Milton's language,
and,
and this,
this conception of taking material and
turning it into a,
a temple to oneself,
um,
was interpreted by Humphrey Jennings,
who was the founder of the mass
observation movement.
And if anyone saw the opening to the
Britains 2012 games,
the history of the industrial
revolution,
he said,
was encapsulated by this passage in
Milton where you have demons building a
temple for themselves out of matter and
that mankind in Milton's language was,
was taught to do this or that they
learned it first by this example.
And he says,
let not envy the devils have riches and
hell.
Um,
and I see things in this one,
the,
the gnostic idea that somehow the world
itself that we inhabit as hell.
And then that matter is not our true
place of,
of existence,
but somewhere sort of platonic and also
the festie and sort of bargain that
people made around 16,
66 two to get a world of stuff and
things and possessions by losing the
soul or what existed before that.
And I,
I wonder if that,
I play with that a lot in my own thought
and I wonder if that's something that
you found in Milton and,
and what you think of that passage in
particular.
Well,
Milton was definitely a prophetic voice,
right?
And I.
and I think that that's,
that's a perfectly reasonable retelling
of that section.
It's also very much a kin to the story
of the Tower of Babel.
We'll talk about next week.
Um,
no.
See the problem with the problem.
God,
it's so complicated.
See what one of the things that young
said about the transformation of the
first millennium of Christianity into
let's say,
the second millennium of Christianity,
is that Christianity had promised
something like redemption,
universal redemption from suffering
maybe in the afterlife.
But that was kind of a cop out,
let's say,
because it didn't really solve the
problem of suffering here and now,
and you believe that as people had.
Although although it did,
many did many positive things,
let's not,
let's not forget that it's civilized
people in a way that they hadn't been
before or you could make that case,
but then there was this underground.
At the same time,
there's this denial of the utility of
material reality that went along with
the spiritualization of mankind in that
in that first in the Christian
millennium,
there was value left in material because
it had been ignored and so young
believer that the,
the,
the collective unconscious,
broadly speaking,
began to be attracted to the,
to what had been rejected by the hyper
spiritualization and started to question
whether or not additional value could be
extracted from the material.
Maybe as a adjunct to the spiritual
because maybe true redemption was
something like a proper meeting of the
spiritual and the material,
which wasn't something that seemed to be
part and parcel of Christian Christian
doctrine.
Up to that point.
Now maybe what Milton was warning
against was a swing too far,
right,
and I think Milton's point is well taken
because one of the things that's worth
noting is that you can be perfectly
miserable in a house of gold,
right?
I mean,
I've known very many wealthy people,
very,
very wealthy people,
and the problem.
See,
the thing is is that money just doesn't
solve that many problems that people
have.
People wish it would.
People who want to be rich think it will
and the people who want to redistribute
money,
you think it will,
and I know that there's nothing to be
said for abject poverty,
but the problem is that there are many
serious problems that human beings have
that matter.
Material Comfort alone does nothing to
address or almost nothing.
You can be perfectly.
You can have a perfectly miserable
family life and $20,
million dollars and the buffer that the
$20,000,000
puts between you and the misery is
sometimes it's not even a buffer.
It's a magnifier.
So Milton would warn against the
creation of even the idea of a material
utopia.
Even in principle,
something Dostoevsky also recognized is
an error,
you cannot solve the problem in that
manner and maybe the demonic idea is
that is propaganda that you could now
maybe,
maybe there is a balance of some sort
because I don't understand if we were
going to build the city of God,
let's say,
well a huge part of the endeavor would
have to be spiritual and to me that a
huge part of that would be,
it would have to be something predicated
if not on truth,
at least not at least on the willingness
of people not to lie to one another.
Without that,
all the material wellbeing in the world
is,
it's a facade.
It's like gilding a corpse.
Right.
And,
and I think that's partly what Melton
was warning against.
I mean Milton was doing many more things
than he knew of course,
because he was a poetic genius of
incalculable genius.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
well you've obviously thought about such
things very much.
So that was a very good question.
So.
All right everyone.
Good.
Thanks.